[Music]
welcome back to the stronger bike
science podcast I'm Greg and I'm Lindsay
and thank you once again for joining us
today and just up here at the top I
would like to express quite a bit of
gratitude for the positive response we
got to our recent episode on aspartame
but I also want to note that you should
not expect that again definitely anytime
soon probably ever uh it was a close to
six hour long episode and it almost put
us in the grave and in fact uh that was
just a hazing ritual Lindsay is is the
new co-host of the show and uh yeah just
just wanted to see if she could tolerate
that type of marathon recording session
and uh she did so barely
barely yeah uh just as a little peek
behind the scenes we sat down to record
it at what like 8 30 or so yeah and we
finished yeah yeah like 8 30 p.m and we
finished at close to 3 A.M yeah or take
um yeah not not doing that take one
break and maybe about three hours in
yeah yeah but I I do think that it's
probably good
um with with Eric and I previously we
had a rough idea of kind of length of
outline to length of episode ratio and
you know there there's a calibration
period uh just to to figure out how that
works and I've never done this at all
before yeah that was my second podcast
episode ever like and I've never been on
a podcast before before doing this so I
tend to over prepare when I'm not
comfortable yet with a medium and I
certainly did that and I knew I was
doing it and yet I couldn't stop myself
and uh we ended up with a six hour
episode but I feel like I you know I've
proven to myself and maybe to the
audience that I can do this
laughs and entirely to me as well I I
hope to not do that again though yeah I
mean just just being completely
transparent looking at the outline I
thought that we were probably staring
down about three or four hours yeah I
thought about four yeah like five and a
half six like that that honestly
surprised me a lot as well yeah but we
did it uh but yeah all of which is to
say uh we certainly appreciate everyone
who listened to the whole episode yeah
it was a lot of content I thought it was
good content drag yeah
um but yeah don't don't expect an
episode of that length again anytime
soon yeah yeah I mean I really
appreciate everyone who expressed their
support for us though because like I
really thought it would be kind of funny
that it was a six hour episode and that
a couple people would really enjoy that
but I thought we likely had found
everyone else's limits and that it was
just not going to go over a while at all
but the response has been really
positive and uh I feel really proud of
that I do as well so uh yeah let's let's
move on from that Lindsay what what has
been on your mind recently do you do you
have any recent bright spots I think we
I think we both have the same today I
think we do and it's love Island love
Island yes so this is our first summer
watching Love Island last summer we
started this season
but ended up starting it like a couple
months in so it just seemed too daunting
to catch up for for people who don't
know about love Island
it is a Daily Show so there are new
episodes coming out every day for an
entire summer so like 60 episodes total
or something for a season and two
episodes some days yes the the new the
new actual content from The Villa but
also after sun yes after sun and unseen
vets but so it was our first summer
watching Love Island we've done it
um with the Hulu stream instead of doing
the VPN so we're like a week behind the
UK which is where it's filmed and so I
think that like yesterday or today was
the day that like
the winners were actually crowned I I
think it's the 31st okay I think it's I
think it's Monday but we're behind yes
and so I'm very nervous about seeing a
spoiler yeah the winners will be known
when this episode comes out but we won't
know the winners until I believe next
Friday hopefully so if we can if we can
avoid the spoilers yes so if you are
also a love Island fan and you either
watch it in the UK in real time or use a
VPN to watch it uh this episode will
drop before Lindsay and I know the
winners so please please don't spoil it
for us please save us yeah but I I guess
like what I'll say why I love love
island is just the chaos of it because
it is filmed and released every day
you see things in the show that have
happened like maybe 12 hours before
sometimes less than 12 hours before it's
almost in real time and that just brings
like such an interesting element to the
show that other reality shows don't have
and there are also people being brought
into the show like new contestants new
Islanders Bombshells have entered the
villa throughout the season and those
people have been watching the show at
home waiting to come on and so they know
everything that's happened they know
more so than the other people who have
been in there and kind of shut off from
the whole internet so it just is this
really interesting Dynamic and it's like
much more wholesome than I expected it
to be like when I heard that everyone
shares a bedroom like all of the couples
are in one giant bedroom I was like oh
that's a little raunchy but it's
actually it's not like it's just very
sweet I like it a lot yeah I feel like I
feel like these these British Lads and
lasses are maybe much much more socially
adjusted or just like less nasty than
American reality contestants maybe so
yeah um yeah it's it's very sweet it's
very cute who who are your who are your
favorite couples in the home stretch I
think Ella and Tyrique should win I
agree I think they've had the best story
throughout they you know they've had
their ups and downs they're a little bit
toxic but you know they're in their
early 20s actually I think Tyrique is
like 26 whatever they're a little bit
toxic but
it's his first like major relationship
and they're working stuff out but they
those kids like each other so much and I
just hope that the British public sees
that
yeah I I hope so as well
um yeah they would also be my pick if I
had a vote but I don't because I think
well one we're not watching it in real
time and two I think I think you need to
have a British phone number to like text
in your boat
um maybe next year we should register a
British phone number if we if yeah if we
go even further down this Rabbit Hole
um but yeah no I I don't know I I also
really like Whitney and Jess yeah but I
don't I mean if if you're voting for
like your favorite or like the strongest
couple I don't think that like the
Whitney lock and pairing has has quite
as much sauce yes
um they're just a newer couple yeah and
lock-in isn't as over the top as Tyrique
yeah and and like I I still have
questions about how into Jess Sammy is I
know honestly
um but yeah whatever for for people who
uh who do also watch Love Island uh feel
free to let us know in the Facebook
group or subreddit yeah who are your
favorites yeah let us let us know what
you think and uh yeah for people who
don't watch Love Island I think we'll
we'll cut it off there because I'm sure
you don't care about any of this join us
next summer yes
um all right so yeah let's let's go
ahead and get into the episode but
before we do that I just need to go
through the standard plugs first if you
listen to the show you like the show go
like rate and subscribe it or go like
and rate it wherever you listen to
podcasts click the Subscribe button if
you haven't already if you're looking
for some excellent coaching to meet your
training nutrition goals Etc uh check
out the stronger by science coaching
program a link to that will be in the
show notes if you're looking for great
supplements for cheap like creatine for
instance uh the topic of this episode
check out bulksupplements.com use the
code SBS POD at checkout for a five
percent discount
if you're looking for a great nutrition
app to track supplements like creatine
or more likely just your food check out
macro factor that is our nutrition app
if you're looking for a great research
review to stay up to date on all of the
relevant research being published being
pumped out these days check out Mass
that's monthly applications and strength
Sports
if you would like to interact with us
like follow the show join the
communities
Etc banter about the episodes and just
for love island or love Island yeah
check out the stronger by science
Facebook group and subreddit that's
reddit.com R Stronger by science or
Stronger by science community on
Facebook uh if you'd like uh breakdowns
of new research and studies sent to your
inbox every other week on the off week
of the podcasts uh subscribe to our
newsletter there will be a link to that
in the show notes as well and uh yeah
that newsletter is primarily just
content we're not going to spam you with
a bunch of sales links and whatnot and
finally uh I've mentioned this the last
couple of episodes but we're doing audio
q and A's on the podcast now uh we're
going we're going to do that for the
first time in this episode if you'd like
to ask a question record an audio clip
that is 60 seconds Max and email it to
podcast at strongerbuyscience.com and if
we like your question we'll answer it on
the show
nice all right let's get into it so uh
as you can see by looking at the episode
title this is an episode about creatine
and some of the popular myths and
misconceptions about creatine so uh just
as just as a jumping off point Lindsay
what what do you know about creatine
yeah
most of what I know has come from just
like being around you and then reading
content that we have published on
Stronger by science it's not necessarily
something I think I would have sought
out if this weren't
my business but I know that it's one of
the most well studied supplements
um I I think like when I've asked you or
like when Eric has talked about it in
the past people always say like the two
best supplements for lifters are
creatine and caffeine like those are the
two things that have been studied the
most and that have the clearest
um effective results
so I know that I know that it's
particularly good for vegetarians and
vegans like I've also heard you
recommend it
to our friends who don't eat meat
because I think
creatine is something that omnivores get
some of in their diet and then if you
don't eat meat you're not getting as
much so you can have a better effect of
taking creatine than the average
omnivore
um in terms of like lifting my
understanding is that it increases the
ability to gain muscle
uh and maybe helps with muscular
endurance in the gym I don't really know
how that works though I know we're going
to get into that I've read it several
times and it's just one of those things
that I read it and my brain is just like
nope we don't we can't process this yeah
that's totally fair yeah
um I also hear about it from macro
Factor users all the time in the groups
because
um I think we'll talk about this too but
people say that when they start taking
creatine they retain water quite a bit
more so their scale weight might go up
in macro factor and they're afraid of
like how that might impact their weight
Trend or their calorie recommendations
but
um my understanding is that it can make
you bloated for a couple days and then
it kind of levels out after that
hmm
in terms of negative things I've heard
about it
um I know we're going to talk about hair
loss that's like the main thing that I
hear and that's mainly just whenever we
publish anything about creatine 60 of
the comments are people asking about
hair loss I don't think I would have
encountered that anywhere else yeah
because it is primarily men asking about
hair loss
um
I've also heard that it can cause like
digestive issues at first like some
people get diarrhea when they first
start taking creatine and it just causes
General tummy troubles for some people
um
I personally have had
um issues with like creatinine levels at
a doctor's office and I've seen people
talking about create like taking
creatine and how that might impact
creatinine but I think those are two
different things and creatinine levels
are just elevated for lifters in general
yeah um
last thing uh this isn't as concrete but
I've also gotten the feeling that a lot
of people particularly people who aren't
into lifting kind of think creatine is a
very intense thing like an intense
supplement to take it's it's only what
the most hardcore people taking that
it's kind of
steroid adjacent yeah so I I am actually
going to talk about that a little bit
when when going through the history okay
um
yeah so what what are um
that's that's a lot honestly uh I'm I'm
very impressed that you've that you've
picked up that much just kind of through
osmosis yeah as someone who doesn't take
creatine and isn't like that interested
in it but yeah if you're swimming in
these Waters and consuming Fitness
content it is hard to avoid just
information about creatine just flowing
over you yeah
um what what are some uh what are some
myths or misconceptions you've heard
about creatine or uh at minimum like
ideas that you've seen floating around
about it that you're not quite sure if
they're true or not
um like you you mentioned like people
saying it's a steroid you mentioned
stuff about hair loss which we're
definitely going to get into on the
episode are there any just other little
things along those lines that come to
mind for you
um I think hair loss is the biggest one
and then like acne and the digestive
issues
I saw some stuff I've seen some stuff
about like it impacting sleep
um
I I don't know if these things are myths
though like these are just things that I
see people saying and I
haven't necessarily sought out
more information to know if it's a myth
because it doesn't really affect me I
got you yeah that that is that is
totally fair
um
so yeah let's uh let's get into it I
think so yeah to to start with I'm just
going to go over a little bit of the
history of of creatine uh but before I
do that I want to just briefly discuss
kind of the the purpose of this episode
okay so like you mentioned before
anytime we publish stuff about creatine
there are a lot of just very kind of
stock common questions and comments we
get in response
um and uh there are a lot of like
statements I see about creatine that
people make very confidently that I
think are based on on very
understandable reasons that aren't quite
true so that that's some of the stuff I
want to discuss uh but yeah we we
recently published a research Spotlight
on Creatine going over a recent
meta-analysis looking at the relative
impact of creatine on muscle growth we
published that we got a lot of comments
and questions and that that just kind of
jogged my brain on a lot of this stuff
and said wow well that that would make a
good podcast episode and also probably a
good research Spotlight as well uh if
you're listening to this there's a
pretty good chance that the research
Spotlight that hits your inbox next week
will be covering uh a lot of very
similar ground because you know a lot a
lot of people like to listen a lot of
people like to read give the people what
they want in both mediums yeah yeah and
a lot of people have this question
absolutely so yeah let's let's talk
about the history a little bit
so creatine was first isolated a long
time ago In 1832
and then through the late 1800s and
early 1900s there were feeding
experiments on animals suggesting that
creatine was absorbed when consumed and
that absorption exceeded excretion like
when they would collect the feces in the
urine so it was being used somehow yeah
yeah but the the fate of the creatine
was controversial okay so some people
thought that it was being absorbed and
just kind of like used for
God knows what like who who know who
know like it's being stored somewhere in
the body as creatine but we don't know
where we don't really know what it's
doing
um other people like since it's a
nitrogen-rich compound they thought that
maybe it was being metabolized and
broken down into just general amino
acids and kind of used like any other
protein would be uh but yeah so late 18
early 1900s there were these experiments
showing that it was absorbed and that
absorption exceeded excretion but the
the fate of it wasn't uh fully known
until a series of experiments by fallen
and Dennis or fallen in Denis in 1912
that that pretty conclusively
established that creatine intake
increased muscle creatine levels in
particular
um and I say pretty conclusively
established because just the the
limitations of the experimental methods
in 1912 were considerable but yeah kind
of impressive that they figured it out
then yeah they established it about as
well as you could establish something in
1912.
um so yeah that that's when that's when
we kind of knew uh with with a
reasonably High degree of confidence
that creatine intake increased body
creatine levels and in particular muscle
creatine levels and then uh
phosphocreatine which just to just to
give like a very very brief bit of
background about how creatine works I I
assume a lot of people listening to this
know already but I'm sure some do not so
essentially creatine is a molecule that
is able to bond with a free phosphate
group forms a compound called
phosphocreatine and the most kind of
acute way that creatine works during
exercise is that you have ATP that's the
energy currency of the cell you use ATP
to power muscle contraction and just all
of the various things going on in the
muscle during exercise and you need to
replenish that ATP like it donates a
phosphate and then it becomes ADP
adenosine diphosphate you need to hook
another phosphate back onto it again to
make it ATP adenosine triphosphate again
so it can it can keep powering muscle
contraction
and so there are various ways that you
can recycle that ATP the the one with
the greatest capacity is oxidative
metabolism just kind of aerobic
metabolism everything that goes on in
the mitochondria Powerhouse of the cell
as we all know but during high intensity
exercise you need you need faster ways
to replenish it if you're going to
maintain performance and so you have
anaerobic glycolysis but you also have
the phosphocreatine system essentially
you have phosphocreatine in your muscles
it's creatine bound to these free
phosphate groups and when ATP is
is replenished by muscle contraction
exercise whatever essentially the ADP
that results from it can just hook up
with the phosphocreatine and say hey
give me that phosphate and that's just a
one step chemical reaction you get a
transfer of the phosphate group from the
phosphocreatine to the ADP you get ATP
out of it
um so like the phosphocreatine basically
gives you a reserve of phosphates that
can be used very very rapidly replenish
ATP during exercise way way faster than
anaerobic glycolysis or oxidative
metabolism and it's still very very
finite but essentially if you didn't
have any other metabolic way to
replenish ATP
um let's say just the the levels of ATP
in your muscle might be able to power
like maximum contraction for you know 6
seven eight seconds something like that
you add phosphocreatine into the mix and
you can use the phosphates hooked on to
those those creatine molecules to
recycle some of that ATP now instead of
like eight to ten seconds of maximal
contraction maybe you can push it to 10
to 12. so that's yeah that's kind of
what it does that was the best
explanation that I've read or seen or
heard I guess well thank you so much
that actually makes sense to me now
um so yeah like that's that's kind of
how how creatine works at least for its
effects on exercise performance
um so phosphocreatine itself was
discovered in 1926. that's like the
actual kind of biologically active
compound that you can use to recycle ATP
um it was discovered in 1926 the
discovery was published in
1927. the researchers were eggleton and
eggleton I assume Brothers uh but they
actually didn't know what it was at
first so they were doing an experiment
uh in frogs looking at like trying to
quantify phosphate levels like inorganic
and organic phosphate levels in the in
the gastroc of frogs
um and they noticed that there was this
organic compound with phosphate in it
that seemed to be depleted under
conditions of fatigue
um basically you you would see
decreases in the this organic phosphate
containing compound and increases in
free inorganic phosphate in the calves
of these frogs as they fatigued but they
didn't know that it was creatine
phosphate they just knew that it was
some organic compound that that had
phosphate in it and they called it
phosphagen so have you heard phosphagen
at all like is is that a word that rings
a bell no but I like that word that's
fun it is it is a cool word
um it's a very intuitive word as well it
basically just means like this seems to
be a source of a lot of the inorganic
phosphates that we see in muscle tissue
like like the Genesis of it
um and sometimes you'll still encounter
this word in part because the first kind
of mass Market creatine supplement was
called phosphogen
um and in part because like since this
was what creatine phosphate or
phosphocreatine was first called in the
scientific literature that
just stuck with some people and that
energy system that I described
previously using the creatine phosphate
to recycle ATP you'll sometimes hear
that referred to as the phosphagen
system so if anyone listening to this
has heard phosphogen and they're like
what where did that come from any of you
old heads are still using words from the
20s or or just people if if you did an
undergrad and exercise physiology like
you've heard phosphogen like that's
interesting it's a common term uh but
yeah I I didn't know where it came from
but yeah it came from just these two
chemists that were doing experiments on
frogs in 1926 who discovered
phosphocreatine and did not know what it
was uh but then later in 1927 another
pair of researchers named Fisk and
sabero uh like
kind of discovered the same compound
again yeah and they were able to
determine that it was creatine phosphate
like essentially when the phosphate
group and the creatine dissociated in
solution they isolated like the compound
that that the phosphates had come from
uh distilled it down and realized like
oh this is creatine like this has been
discovered before we know what it is so
yeah the phosphagen that eggleton and
eggleton talked about it's creatine
phosphate so uh yeah 1927 is when it was
discovered nice but at the time no one
knew the import of that uh so
phosphocreatine was actually discovered
before ATP was uh ATP wasn't discovered
until 1929. that's wild yeah
um
and also the purpose of ATP wasn't uh
it wasn't like fully established until
later but it wasn't even hypothesized
until 1941. uh so these initial
discoveries were just by chemists who
were trying to figure out ways to
isolate and quantify the phosphate or
the phosphorus content of tissues and
they just kept running into these pesky
organic compounds that contained
phosphorus that were where it was
difficult to like isolate the phosphorus
or the phosphate from the organic
compounds yeah so they're like yeah
there's this called phosphocreatine
there's this there's this called
ATP like we don't know what any of it
does but like we're we're just trying to
measure the phosphorus here
um so yeah in in 1941 the actual purpose
of ATP was first hypothesized it donates
its phosphate group that's an exothermic
reaction the combination of of the
phosphate group kind of changing the
confirmation of proteins and also the
energy released being able to catalyze
actions like like ATP serving is kind of
the the stock energy currency of of a
cell that was first hypothesized in the
40s
um so then from 41 when the purpose of
of ATP was first hypothesized until the
60s the purpose of phosphocreatine still
wasn't known
um people were starting to get inklings
based on the fact that it seemed to be
kind of similar to ATP during fatiguing
exercise you would see phosphates being
dissociated from ATP you would see them
being dissociated from phosphocreatine
so it's like okay we we think that this
probably has something to do with energy
metabolism
um but a lot of people actually felt
that phosphocreatine was basically like
a different form of ATP yeah where that
didn't make sense as something to think
yeah like it makes intuitive sense too
because you do have like particularly
high levels of phosphocreatine in your
muscles which do experience really
really high energy demands during
exercise and you also have like spec
special versions of other molecules at
relatively high levels in muscle tissue
that were being discovered around this
time as well so like hemoglobin that's
what carries oxygen in your blood you
also have a very similar compound in a
lot of tissues but in particularly high
levels in muscle called myoglobin the
the myo root means muscle
um and it it basically serves the same
purpose but like since energy needs and
therefore oxygen needs are can be so
high in muscle you kind of have this
other hemoglobin like compound that is
in relatively high levels in muscle to
kind of like grab that oxygen transport
it where it needs to go store a little
bit of it for the muscle so a lot of
people thought phosphocreatine worked
similarly like hey use ATP for for
energy to power muscle contraction
whatever the energy demands in skeletal
muscle are are very spiky like they're
often very low but then they're
extremely high during exercise
so yeah it would kind of make sense to
have a a sort of backup ATP
um but then in the 60s what
phosphocreatine actually does was
established like it's not directly
donating its phosphate to say like the
myosin head to power muscle contraction
it's donating it to the ATP or the ADP
to make more ATP yeah
um so yeah like the 60s were when the
basic biochemistry of phosphocreatine
was was fully worked out or worked out
close enough to fully worked out
um
but then there was
about a 30-year lag before people
started trying to use it for ergogenic
purposes yeah and in the era that kind
of makes sense be because uh there
wasn't there wasn't really drug testing
in that era and so the the the
biochemistry was in place for people to
maybe hypothesize that hey if I took
creatine maybe that's going to increase
muscle creatine stores uh that's going
to give me a way to re-phosphorylate ATP
a little bit better like like the pieces
were there but drug testing wasn't
really a thing so it's like why why
would I around with that when I can
just blast gear you know uh we know that
works yeah so uh around the late 80s was
when drug testing especially like in the
Olympics but in other sports as well
started getting a lot more serious
um and that also seems to be around the
time people started experimenting with
creatine as a supplement to improve
performance
um and creatine first entered the
mainstream in 1992.
yeah it's surprisingly recent
um I I just say that because that's
around the time I was born I was like
wow that was just yesterday yeah yeah
very very very recent uh yeah like what
was that maybe like 20 years ago give or
take 20 25 who knows
um but yeah so there was a British
Sprinter named lynford Christie who won
the 100 meter uh Sprint at the Barcelona
Olympics in 92 and uh
so Christy himself already had a history
of being a drug cheat so he had been
found to be taking a banned stimulant in
the 1988 Seoul Olympics
um and this was also an era when people
were pretty sensitive to doping in
sports especially in sprinting because
also in those same 1988 Olympics that
was when uh Ben Johnson Canadian
Sprinter beat Carl Lewis uh American
Sprinter and long jumper and just all
around like monster track and field
athlete uh but yeah Ben Johnson beat
Carl Lewis in the 100 meter finals in in
those Olympics and then Ben Johnson
tested positive for steroids uh
specifically stenosolol uh which I think
is is Winstrol like I think that's what
most people call it yeah
um I'm not totally sure about that I'm
yeah
but I I think I think that's what it is
whatever it does it it's a steroid yeah
but yeah Ben Johnson got pop for gear
um
and uh so yeah there there were already
like suspicions and and kind of bad
vibes around Linford Christie for his
for his getting caught taking band
stimulants uh a lot of kind of concern
around drug use in the hundred meters in
particular due to the the prior Olympics
and then after Linford Christie won the
100 meter finals it came out that he was
taking creatine oh no and I think I
think this is where the the common uh
just completely wrong yeah misconception
that creatine is a steroid comes from
that makes sense they're like this is a
this is a guy who does steroids and here
he is doing this new thing that we
haven't heard about yet that any that no
one else is doing so at the time at the
time Linford Christie Hannah had been
called using steroids it was the
previous hundred meter Champion Ben
Johnson but like there was the
association between steroids and the
hundred meters and Linford Christie was
also bust did using steroids later in
his career
um but yeah like so it was kind of The
Perfect Storm for
this guy wins 100 meters in a relatively
dirty sport yeah in the Olympics uh
people find out he's taking this thing
called creatine which most people hadn't
heard of like it wasn't a common
supplement and so then I I think that is
kind of the cultural soup from which the
idea that creatine is a steroid emerged
but it's also the set of conditions that
made it a popular consumer supplement
yeah so after the news broke that
Linford Christie had been taking
creatine uh a company called EAS dropped
to the first consumer creatine product
on the market the very next year in 1993
called which they called phosphogen and
uh yeah the the creatine Market just
kind of exploded after that
were other supplements popular at this
time do you know that off the top of
your head oh man
there were I think by the early 90s
there were already some like really
disgusting protein supplements on the
market okay like like this was yeah this
was before uh like the reverse osmosis
process for like creatine isolate had
gotten good so I think I think the prior
process for making like whey protein
supplements was essentially you get a
vat of whey like just the byproduct from
the cheese making process and kind of
cook it down
um which
will give you a powder but also kind of
produces some all flavors as well like
it I I haven't taken any of like the
very OG protein supplements but everyone
I've talked to that that has uh
basically says like you kids these days
you don't know how good you had it like
back in my day the the protein we took
was dog uh I believe it going back
even further people used to take liver
tabs which was basically just like dried
desiccated liver uh that was either
pressed into tablets or
um like powdered and put into capsules
okay
um which was also a good source of
protein and also potentially a
dangerously high source of vitamin A oh
perfect uh but also like iron and a
bunch of other micro nutrients as well
like eating liver is good for you every
once in a while yeah yeah but but yeah
so that was another like very very early
supplement that people used to take I
don't really know why what else was on
the market like I'm sure people were
already using caffeine for ergogenic
purposes but like really the consumer
supplement market like like sports
supplements uh really came into its own
around the same time drug testing did
because because again yeah like why are
you gonna around with like
citrulline or beta alanine or creatine
when you can just blast gear you know
what I mean
um so yeah like I I don't know like I
don't have a full accounting of like the
history of this of the sport supplement
Market but my understanding is that it
roughly coincided with when drug testing
became a lot more common yeah yeah that
was kind of what I was assuming so I
just kind of wanted to check that
assumption and it also makes sense why
that like creatine is a steroid thing
kind of started circulating is because
there just weren't other supplements
yeah around at the time so it's like
well we know that athletes use one thing
steroids so this is likely something
that has an effect similar to that yeah
yeah for sure uh but yeah so that's
that's kind of the history of creatine
up to the present day ish I don't think
I don't think there have been any like
major developments from there yeah the
biochemistry was known people started
doing more research on it for kind of
ergogenic purposes
um it became like a pretty big consumer
product right from the jump and yeah
that that gets us to the present day
um so yeah let's let's get into some of
the myths and misconceptions floating
around about creatine uh one of the
common ones is that creatine causes hair
loss yeah uh I I know you've heard about
that because you you read the comments
on our Instagram posts
um have you heard or read anything about
the the Genesis of that idea like where
where it comes from
I know
or my understanding is that it's from a
singular study in 2009
yeah that is that is a hundred percent
correct uh and did you come across
anything or anyone discussing what it
was about that paper that made people
think that creatine might cause hair
loss yes let me see if I can if I can
remember it exactly I mean it was
something like the DHT levels that
creatine was associated with increased
DHT levels and DHT levels are associated
with
hair loss
specifically in men yeah yeah so that
that is that is the common accounting of
it okay uh the first part is correct or
at least is kind of a correct read of
that study the second part may not be
entirely correct and that's about the
DHT causing the increased DHT causing
hair loss DHT levels causing hair okay
okay so that that's a that's an
important bit of nuance yeah that that
gets completely stripped yes that even
the people I've seen pushing back
against are like trying to debunk this
claim haven't really touched on yeah
um so yeah if if you're listening to
this and you've heard people uh
previously dunk on the claim that
creatine causes hair loss uh keep
listening like I I think that even most
of the folks that try to debunk this
claim do miss something that's very big
and also very critical about this topic
uh that I'm going to discuss
um so yeah but yeah what what you what
you talked about is is essentially
correct like where this idea comes from
yeah
um and so just as a little bit of
background information on DHT and this
topic in general DHT stands for
dihydrotestosterone it is a metabolite
of testosterone proper and uh there's
this enzyme called five Alpha reductase
which is what converts testosterone to
DHT uh primarily in men it does also
cause that diver that conversion in
women but a lot of the DHT in women is
converted from another hormone called
androstein Dione but that's another
topic
um but yeah and DHT Works basically the
same way testosterone does and uh
basically the same way that steroid
hormones in general do so it's since
it's a steroid hormone it's built on a
cholesterol backbone that means it's
lipid it's soluble so it can diffuse
straight into a cell and from there it
binds to an androgen receptor and that
ligand receptor complex which is what
you would call it
translocates to the nucleus where it
affects Gene transcription gene
expression so like that that's how
steroid hormones work they bind to a
receptor the ligand receptor complex
goes to the nucleus it affects Gene
transcription and since DHT binds to the
same Androgen receptor testosterone does
it has basically the same effects that
testosterone would like it's going to
influence expression of the same genes
cause creation of the same proteins
cause kind of the same changes in
cellular biochemistry but DHT has about
five times greater receptor affinity for
the Androgen receptor than testosterone
does so it basically has the same
effects but more pronounced kind of per
per unit of DHT like like one like one
gram of DHT would cause similar effects
as one gram of testosterone but like
five times as much of them oh wow more
more or less like like not exactly
because then you have to talk about like
receptor density and like a bunch of
other but like it's essentially
like super testosterone like that's
that's a reasonable way to think about
it
um and like you mentioned DHT is
implicated in hair loss in particular
the most common type of hair loss which
is called androgenic alopecia used to be
called male pattern baldness
um and then people discovered that kind
of similar mechanisms worked in women as
well although it's a less common thing
so they used to call it male pattern
baldness and also a female pattern
baldness and now it's just kind of all
lumped together as androgenic alopecia
because alopecia hair loss androgenic
caused by androgens yeah DHT being an
androgen so that's that's where that
name comes from and uh the most popular
anti-hair loss drugs uh function by
being five Alpha reductase Inhibitors or
five Alpha reductase uh antagonists so
essentially what they do is is they kind
of like clog up this receptor so that
testosterone is still floating around or
not this receptor but this enzyme so
that testosterone is floating around but
the enzyme that would convert it to DHT
can't convert it to DHT and that does
seem to be very effective at reducing
hair loss if you have hair loss because
of androgenic alopecia
um so that that kind of creates the idea
that DHT levels yeah are associated with
or like if DHT levels get too high
that's going to cause hair loss so
that's kind of the necessary background
information for the 2009 study which
will be linked in the show notes but the
title is three weeks of creatine
monohydrate supplementation affects
dihydrotestosterone to testosterone
ratio in college aged rugby players uh
don't know how to pronounce the the lead
author's name but it it would be
phonetically pronounced Van Der merway I
suppose but yeah that'll that'll be
linked in the show notes if anyone wants
to read it
uh and so this was a pretty
straightforward crossover study there
were 20 male rugby players initially
recruited they were randomized into two
groups there were four total dropouts so
you wind up with eight subjects per
group
um and kind of it was a crossover study
so there were two there were two parts
of the study essentially and during each
part of the study there was a creatine
group and a placebo group
um where essentially like to start with
one group took creatine the other took a
placebo yeah you you have that phase
then you have a washout period and then
the people who initially took creatine
now take the placebo the people who
previously took the placebo now take the
creatine and you just do the same thing
again yeah
um so yeah the the like each each kind
of leg of the study had a seven day
loading period where the people taking
creatine took 25 grams of creatine which
is a lot per day uh per day yeah that's
a lot uh yeah like 20 25 grams is like a
typical loading phase Okay so
when when I use creatine I generally
just forego the loading phase yeah and
we'll talk about this later I've heard
about that though like that you take you
have the loading phase and then you kind
of even out after that yeah so you can
either take a really high dose for like
a week yeah and then a lower dose to
kind of maintain it or you can just
start with the lower dose and instead of
fully saturating your muscle creatine
levels in uh usually a loading phase
lasts a week but generally you're fully
saturated after like three or four days
but instead of taking three or four days
to saturate it takes like three or four
weeks to saturate uh but I just don't
want to deal with the loading phase so I
I don't do it yeah most of the stuff
that I've seen about like
gastrointestinal issues is like when
people are in that loading phase yes yes
absolutely so maybe take three weeks if
you don't want to your pants yes uh
but yeah so since each kind of segment
of this study was was just three weeks
long they would do a one week loading
phase followed by 14 days with a
maintenance dose of five grams of
creatine uh and then there was a six
week washout between phases which would
be plenty of time to get creatine levels
back to Baseline yeah like it takes
about a month after you stop
supplementing for creatine levels to get
back to Baseline so you just tack two
extra weeks on like six weeks kind of a
better safe than sorry uh type of amount
of time
um so yeah that that's kind of what
happened in the study and then in terms
of results
um people people reporting that the
study found that creatine uh
supplementation increased DHT do seem to
be mostly correct so during the placebo
uh arm of the study
um you saw
like
non-significant decreases in DHT levels
during the three weeks so it was
starting at 1.26 nanomoles per liter and
ended at 1.06 in animals per liter but
given the kind of typical amount of
variability that wasn't a statistically
significant change in the creatine
condition they were starting at 0.98 in
animals per liter uh got up to 1.53
after the loading phase and ended at
1.38 in animals per liter so there there
was kind of a general Trend towards
increasing in the the magnitude of the
increase was statistically significant
and the different effects between arms
were statistically significant as well
um so yeah uh that's broadly what the
study found like it did suggest that
creatine supplementation might increase
blood DHT levels uh but there there are
a couple things to note about that the
first is that at all time points DHT
levels were comfortably within the
normal range so the the lowest
measurement at any point in time was
kind of the creatine arm
pre-study which was at .98 animals per
liter the highest observed at any point
was after the loading phase in the
creatine condition it was 1.53 nanomoles
per liter and the reference range for
DHT levels like you can find different
ranges from different sources but for
men uh which which you tend to see is
somewhere around 0.5 to 2.5 nanimals per
liter we'll link a source in the show
notes
um that uh specifically like gives a
reference range of 0.47 to 2.65
nanomoles per liter but you can you can
see like slightly different reference
ranges from different sources but I
haven't seen one where the bottom end of
the reference range was above 0.98 or
the top end of the reference range was
below 1.53 like like the values observed
we're not seeing like huge noteworthy
changes in DH T levels like it's it's
all just fluctuations within the normal
range you would expect to see what
exactly does reference range mean
um so when when you go to the doctor and
you get blood work done uh and say you
look at your
I don't know like blood urea nitrogen
levels like bu in yeah you see that on
on your blood test uh there will be a
number next to your test result and then
there will be a range on the right side
of the sheet that shows
the reference range for it which is just
kind of like what you normally observe
in healthy people okay okay where if
your levels of whatever are below that
reference range that suggests that like
hey we we know that most people like
this particular metabolite or biomarker
is within this range so if you're like
comfortably below the bottom of that
range maybe there's something going on
causing this biomarker to be below the
range or if it's way above the range
maybe there's something nefarious going
on to make it be above the range but
yeah the reference range is just kind of
like what are the values we typically
see in healthy people okay
um but yeah so so DHT levels were within
the reference range in both conditions
at all time points so one even if we did
confidently say that creatine increased
DHT levels
um you wouldn't expect it to do anything
particularly interesting unless it was
increasing DHT levels above the top end
of that reference range typically
um second is that these results could
just be the result of kind of
statistical noise and normal variation
yeah so DHT concentrations in serum
within a single individual can vary
within about a two-fold range
um so you know someone who goes in and
gets their DHT levels checked and it's
one nanimal per liter today maybe they
go back in three days and it's two
nanimals per liter and they're kind of
typical level if you measured them every
day for a month would average out at one
and a half like that that's kind of the
the range you tend to see interesting
um
and so like if this was a study with
like a hundred subjects
those sorts of things like like typical
just day-to-day variation that we could
be quite confident that it would all
just come out in the wash yeah and so
group level changes we see over time are
probably indicative of actual group
level changes in a study with just 16
subjects that completed it that might be
a small enough subject number uh and the
variation in DHT levels within
individuals might be large enough that
we would see these results just purely
by chance yeah um like that's not
outside the realm of possibility and
then also the finding that
um that creatine increased DHT levels
like it could also just be kind of
chance variation just from like a a
weirdly low low Baseline number so
um
like Day Zero for both arms like the the
pre supplementation measurements in
theory should have been the same between
the creatine condition and the placebo
condition
um but it wasn't it was like 1.26 with
Placebo and 0.98 with creatine
um and where creatine wound up 1.38
that's not too different from Baseline
and Placebo which was 1.26
um so yeah like the the
finding of the changes over time in the
creatine group might just kind of be an
artifact of them starting with
exceptionally low DHT levels compared to
a lot of the other measurements for
reasons that no one knows so it might
also be like a little bit of smoke and
mirrors
um
and so yeah those are the typical
criticisms you'll hear people throw out
when discussing this study uh when when
trying to throw water on the idea that
creatine causes hair loss like yeah the
changes in DHT we're seeing here aren't
scary like it's staying within the
reference ranges relatively small sample
size lower Baseline measures in the
creatine condition like yeah and so uh
yeah like just don't worry about it like
that that is kind of where the research
criticism here ends
um but we can go multiple steps deeper
which is
that this finding is
almost entirely or maybe completely
entirely irrelevant to hair loss so
uh
you want to talk about that yeah okay so
yeah so the the study in rugby players
at everyone's sites saying ah creatine
increases DHT levels DHT causes hair
loss creatine is going to cause hair
loss very scary
it was measuring serum DHT levels so DHT
levels in the blood and blood levels of
DHT mean not a goddamn thing when it
comes to hair loss okay so that was
something I was going to ask yeah yes so
um I there's going to be a lot of
research linked here uh in the show
notes for people who really want to get
into this but I just I just pulled out a
quote from a 2018 review titled
androgens and androgen receptor action
in skin and hair follicles that that
kind of sets the stage for this segment
that quote is as no correlation between
pattern of baldness and serum Androgen
has been found the pathogenic action of
androgens is likely to be mediated
through the intracellular signaling of
hair follicle target cells so did that
make sense to you no okay so it will in
a little bit okay great the the basic
takeaway is that circulating blood
levels of DHT aren't what cause baldness
okay so there have been studies that
have looked at like people with
androgenic alopecia people without it
looking at correlations between
testosterone levels and DHT levels and
likelihood of baldness or rate of
progression of androgenic alopecia or
all of these things or just group
comparisons like you take some people
who are bald some people who aren't bald
yeah and just look like do these people
have different blood levels of these
androgens yeah they don't uh so the
reference range like in terms of what
that means for baldness like doesn't
actually mean anything right so the the
rest it doesn't matter that it was not
that it was within the reference range
like that's a a tidy thing for people
trying to explain this with the with the
assumption that DHT might cause hair
loss but like even if they found levels
above that reference range like that
wouldn't actually indicate anything
um
probably okay like so most of the DHT in
your blood is a DHT that was generated
in peripheral tissues that didn't that
then didn't end up getting metabolized
in those tissues so it does get into the
blood So like
um if if you did see like a five-fold
increase in DHT levels when people took
creatine that might suggest that you're
seeing like pretty big differences or
pretty big changes in peripheral DHT
metabolism
um
so the the fact that it was still within
the reference range I think is still
like noteworthy and somewhat important
um but yeah like it it also like the
serum levels just don't seem to be
particularly relevant okay
um so yeah circulating DHT isn't what
causes baldness it seems to primarily be
a matter of DHT conversion in the hair
follicles themselves so you have
systemic hormones and you also have
otocrine and paracrine hormones and
systemic hormones are essentially
I'm in and some hormones are like
systemic but then they also have like
otocrine and paracrine functions and I I
see your look of confusion I'm about to
explain what I'm talking about but
systemic hormones are hormones that are
generally produced entirely or almost
entirely in a single organ and that
organ releases them into the bloodstream
and then the hormone goes to wherever it
needs to go and has whatever effect it
needs to have okay so like uh insulin is
a great example yeah you produce it in
your pancreas the pancreas releases it
into the bloodstream and it travels from
the pancreas to other tissues and has
effects in other tissues but like uh so
like create or insulin has effects in
muscle but like muscle isn't producing
its own insulin like it so right it's
coming it's a systemic hormone
um testosterone is also primarily a
systemic hormone so you do have actually
like kind of a lot of tissues that can
produce a little testosterone but most
of the testosterone you you have uh in
males is produced in the testes in women
produced in the ovaries a little bit in
the adrenal glands as well and it's
primarily produced in those tissues and
it goes systemically and does whatever
it needs to do DHT is primarily an
otocrine and paracrine hormone which
means that most of the DHT that a
particular tissue uses to do stuff is
made in that tissue itself
so your your body makes testosterone or
in the case of women androstein Dione
that goes to the skin and then the skin
kind of absorbs that testosterone or
androstine Dione and says hey we we need
some androgenic action so we are going
to convert this testosterone to DHT here
in the skin and then it's going to do
what it needs to do
um so that and that's what otocrine and
paracrine means like autocrine means a
cell making a hormone for its own
purpose paracrine means basically local
action like you know uh skin cell that's
like four skin cells away from some
other skin cell might make some DHT and
it just kind of diffuses through the
local cells yeah as kind of a localized
effect okay and so yeah DHT is primarily
in autocrine and paracrine hormone it is
not primarily a systemic hormone and so
systemic levels of DHT are typically not
particularly informative of anything so
when we're talking about effects on
baldness we are interested about kind of
DHT action and Metabolism in the scalp
itself yeah so
as kind of like supporting evidence for
that scalp areas that are more likely to
become bald have higher levels of the
five Alpha reductase enzyme than scalp
areas that are less likely to become
bald like if uh if someone took a little
biopsy of the scalp on the top of your
head yeah which is where you're most
likely to go bald and took a biopsy of
your scalp near the back of your head
where very very few people go bald yeah
and just looked at five Alpha reductase
levels in those two biopsies they they'd
see that you have way way higher levels
of the enzyme that converts testosterone
to DHT on the top of your head than on
the back of your head
um and people with androgenic alopecia
just have higher scalp levels of DHT
than people who don't even though they
have very similar systemic levels of DHT
okay so you measure it in the blood
people with and without baldness look
like they have very similar DHT levels
you look at DHT in the scalp itself way
higher in people with Androgen and
alopecia yeah
um are people
testing that themselves no no no no like
that's
uh and typically like I don't think a
doctor would usually even test for they
just look at the pattern of the baldness
and be like you have androgenic
allergies yeah we're just gonna put you
on the dress they're not gonna give us
skin biopsy right from your head that's
good um yeah but but like when they
study this in a lab like that's that's
what they see
um
and there's also some research
suggesting that there might just be
higher Androgen receptor density in
people who are prone to baldness and in
the areas of the scalp that are likely
to go bald
um although that's controversial the bit
about the areas of the scalp likely to
go bald having higher angiogen receptor
density like that's that's known okay
whether or not it's a difference in
density of Androgen receptors or just
sensitivity of Androgen receptors and
people predispose versus not predisposed
to baldness like that's that's still
kind of an open question uh but yeah
like so it's it's all about local stuff
um and so like DHT is definitely
important for hair loss uh taking drugs
that stop the conversion of testosterone
to DHT uh is sufficient to stop the
progression of hair loss but again it's
it's about the local action not yeah
systemic blood levels of DHT uh so then
the next logical question is well what
what
underlying sets of conditions calls
scalp DHT levels to increase to cause
hair loss
and there is surprisingly like with
with uh becoming bald being such a
common fear yeah that people have
especially men and with kind of the hair
loss drug industry being so big you
would think that there would be like a
full accounting of the the pathogenesis
of uh androgenic alopecia but there's
not like there there are still a lot of
unresolved questions in this area
um but one possibility and one one thing
that's like relatively commonly accepted
is that kind of hypoxia or blood flow
seems to be pretty important so scalp
blood flow is really really high
um it's about 10 times greater than skin
blood flow to other regions wow which if
you've ever got a head wound you know
that like have you ever gotten a head
wound no uh I have those
don't stop bleeding like it yeah they
bleed so much because the scalp has such
high AI levels of of blood flow to it
um
and men with androgenic alopecia have
rates of scalp blood flow that are way
lower than men without androgenic
alopecia like 60 yeah
um and so like one possibility is that
uh essentially like something happens to
decrease scalp blood flow DHT generally
promotes angiogenesis like the growth of
new blood vessels so maybe something is
causing a decrease in Scout blood flow
your your skin cells in your scalp say
hey we're just going to start creating
more DHT because we're trying to promote
vascularization but then that has the
side effect of causing hair loss okay
um but there are other like potential
accountings for this so the
this next idea I'm going to throw out I
think is is wrong but it's interesting
so the first one you said that seems
very plausible but that is is that still
just kind of a theory
um so like a lot of people think that
blood flow is is important yes whether
the DHT increase is like directly
mechanistically caused by the decrease
in blood flow or whether they have a
common cause like there's
um that's where there's a lot more
discussion okay
um but yeah so there's uh there's this I
believe Turkish guy
um doctor
tuner I think
um who is of the is of the opinion that
it's all about gravity uh which okay
which is a very funny
um yeah so this review paper will be
will be linked in the show notes as well
um but yeah so he proposes that what
actually causes hair loss is a feedback
loop caused by gravity and the thinning
of the subcutaneous fat layer on the top
of the head
um so essentially like one one thing
that's noteworthy about male pattern
baldness Androgen and alopecia is that
it really is just like the top of the
head that goes bald yes like the sides
of the head back of the head mostly
keeps the hair yes
um and so
he and when you think about how gravity
would act it's pulling straight down and
so that that is technically creating and
it's acting on all tissues so it is
technically pulling the skin on the top
of your head down into your scalp
whereas the skin on the side of your
head it's maybe like creating a shearing
Force against your scalp but it's not
like directly pushing it into your scalp
does that make sense yes
um and so I mean kind of okay uh but
yeah so he he your explanation makes
sense the theory is interesting oh man
this this is a really fun paper like
there's there's fun little drawings of
like of heads of of heads and how
gravity would act all these different
regions of the head and he's like yeah
we we see that like right where you
would get that cut off of Gravity
pushing stuff down onto the top of the
head versus not like that's that's what
circumscribes the area that goes which
okay I I think that it's a matter of
mistaken correlation but I I see where
he's coming from yeah um so yeah he is
he essentially proposes that okay so
another little bit of background
information okay there's there's this
thing when you read research in this
area that people will refer to as the
DHT Paradox the DHT Paradox is that some
hair on your body doesn't seem to be
particularly sensitive to DHT at all
right so like your eyebrows or your
eyelashes or hair on the sides and back
of your head doesn't really seem to be
influenced by tht levels other hair does
so for men like facial hair the hair
follicles that create facial hair are
very sensitive to DHT if you never
produce DHT like if if you were
castrated for instance you don't grow a
beard a mustache yeah
um also like body hair armpit hair pubic
hair those hair follicles are sensitive
to DHT as well and the hair on the top
of your head also sensitive to DHT okay
in most parts of your body where you
have hair that's sensitive to DHT it's
net anabolic like it causes hair to grow
where it didn't previously right in the
case of facial hair yeah I mean like you
have the follicles but like they're
producing like little baby white hairs
yeah so like big big thick facial hair
hairs
um or like body hair pubic hair whatever
like it's pro-anabolic it makes like it
activates these follicles and makes them
grow bigger thicker hair than than they
did previously nice whereas on the top
of the head it seems to be net catabolic
yeah like the the way
the way that uh
um
like the bald the baldness actually
progresses with androgenic alopecias
through a process of hair
minimization I think I think that's what
they call it like just thinning well
basically like the hair follicle itself
gets smaller and smaller and smaller
over time yeah the hairs themselves get
finer finer and finer and finer over
time and eventually the hair follicle
just gets so small that no hair hairs
can't poke out of it anymore
um so yeah interesting and so it causes
most
Androgen sensitive hair follicles to get
bigger like it's now anabolic whereas
top of the head it causes those Androgen
sensitive follicles to get smaller it's
net catapults yeah and you're not like
losing your beard when you get old
correct yeah
um so yeah you'll you'll often see this
referred to as the Androgen Paradox or
the DHT Paradox and and this guy is
proposing that it's not a paradox at all
okay in fact DHT is still pro-anabolic
for the Androgen sensitive follicles on
the top of the head like it is for
facial hair and body hair but the
problem is as the subcutaneous layer of
fat gets thinner there's essentially
more pressure between the follicle
itself and like your skull
and and the fat is Getting Thinner
because of gravity right
the the fat well
gravity age what like in this theory in
the DHT itself okay okay
um but yeah so as the subcutaneous fat
layer gets thinner there's less kind of
soft tissue for the hair follicle to
grow down into okay so DHT production
increases to promote follicle growth so
they can kind of like have have a bit
more biochemical push behind them to
grow down
far enough so that they can grow full
hairs but uh DHT and androgens in
general tend to promote thinning of
subcutaneous fat layers so it's like
basically the DHT is trying to call like
like trying to fix the problem by
helping these hair follicles grow down
and get large enough but it's also
exacerbating the problem by thinning
that subcutaneous fat layer even more
which then makes the deleterious effects
of gravity putting pressure on the
follicles like like magnified and it's
basically a positive feedback loop okay
um
anyway I I think that's completely wrong
um but it it is it drops to him though
for for his theory yeah it's it's a fun
native yeah it's a fun idea
um the biggest issue with it is that
like the DHT paradox
isn't like really that much of a paradox
anymore like no it used to be but
um now we have at least like a slightly
better though still not full kind of
mechanistic metabolic accounting of why
DHT is net anabolic and some follicles
and net catabolic and others
um so this comes from in vitro studies
primarily where they'll take like
follicle cells from like the top of the
head versus the back of the head
um and just culture them in a Petri dish
and then expose them to DHT and see hey
what happens do you get bigger do you
get smaller what what hormones do you
release in response to this DHT and what
they find is that for follicles from the
top of the head when you expose them to
DHT in a in a Petri dish
um they tend to get smaller and uh you
get suppressed growth of co-cultured
keratinocytes which are like the the
cells that actually make the hair
um and for like beard hairs that are
cultured and then exposed to to DHT you
do see enhanced growth and also enhanced
growth of co-cultured keratinocytes it's
like it is actually having like net
different effects yeah
um
and it seems to be largely as a result
of like the secondary hormones that are
released in response to DHT so in
um like in in the beard hairs for
instance you get an increase in igf-1
levels which is kind of a net anabolic
hormone does a lot of growth related
stuff yeah whereas for follicle cells
taken from the top of the head you see
an increase in something called
transforming growth factor One beta
which seems to be what's kind of telling
the keratino side it's like ah hey don't
grow quite as much
um so yeah essentially you just get like
different secondary hormones being
released in response to DHT so yeah his
whole idea is based upon the idea that
like DHT does still promote follicle
growth at the top of the head but it
doesn't
but I do think that
um
I do think that like we shouldn't fully
throw the the baby out with the bath
water like it is it is possible that the
thinning of the subcutaneous fat layer
is still relevant yeah one of the
reasons I say that is that like
you do see a thinning of subcutaneous
fat with age and you also see an
increase in balding with age many also
see a decrease in Androgen levels and
like DHD conversion with age yeah so it
could just be that like you know maybe
the DHT levels in part cause hair loss
by contributing to thinning of the
subcutaneous fat layer but like a lot of
the other parts of this Theory don't
seem to be particularly well supported
uh there was a similar hypothesis as
well that
is is also similarly interesting that I
think is a little bit more convincing
um so
it is from uh
it was published in in the journal
medical hypotheses in 2018 from a guy
named Robert S English Jr and
um
his idea is basically that like what's
actually causing this like what's what's
putting you down the road towards
baldness is scalp tension uh essentially
proposing that chronic scalp tension is
causing an inflammatory response and
that stimulates uh increased DHT
production like increased levels of the
five Alpha reductase enzyme to cause
increased DHT production
um so like you you often see increases
in Androgen levels in response to like
inflammation or cell damage
um in part because they help like Tamp
down on the inflammatory response
getting excessive so
um
androgens tend to have like weak to
moderate immunosuppressant yeah effects
which is one reason why like men tend to
get sick a little bit more frequently
than women do
um and they also generally promote
anabolism or anabolism so like if a cell
has been damaged you kind of need
something saying like hey let's increase
protein synthesis to like repair this
damage like uh uh create like build new
proteins to replace the ones that have
been damaged so like you often see
increases in Androgen levels as part of
the response to inflammation so he he's
proposing that chronic scalp tension
increases in inflammation that is what
causes the DHT production and then the
DHT promotes thickening of the dermal
sheath
perifollicular fibrosis
um and calcification of the blood
vessels of the scalp leading to the
decreases in blood flow and uh those in
addition to kind of like the direct
actions of of DHT on the follicles
themselves like that's what ultimately
results in hair loss and there's a bit
of uh of incidental support for this
which is that and and I didn't know this
before digging into this body of
research did you know Botox is being
studied as a treatment for hair loss
usually seems to work pretty well
um like it seems to like other hair loss
drugs uh reduce the progression of of
androgenic alopecia related hair
thinning there's also some research
suggesting that it might like allow for
some hair regrowth wow um and
uh the the mechanistic accounting of it
isn't fully known it it basically it was
discovered by accident where people were
just using Botox and injections for the
reason people use botox uh and then they
kind of notice like hey I seem to be
like growing some hair back this this is
weird
um
and so yeah the the way in which are
they putting it like in the top of their
head uh no it can be anywhere okay so so
fun little bit of like musculoskeletal
anatomy of the head okay so uh
oh yes I remember what it's called okay
you have a single muscle called your
occipital frontalis of course which
um so there there's like a muscle along
the occiput of your skull which is just
like the back of your skull okay and the
the frontal bone which is like your
forehead and it's connected by a single
like tendon sheath like like long flat
tendon called a aponeurosis like that's
what you call like a uh like a thin
sheet of tendon
um but yeah so you basically have like a
single muscle with two bellies where the
bellies are just
separated by the top of your head okay
but they're connected by like a single
tendon Chief yeah and so if you're
trying to reduce like wrinkling in your
forehead with botox very popular place
to get BOTOX yeah you get injections
into your the the frontal belly of your
occipital frontalis
um yeah so that would also reduce scalp
tension a little bit
um and so that that might be how it
promotes okay hair regrowth if like the
reduction in scalp tension causes a
reduction in DHT levels because you you
have less of that inflammatory response
anyway I thought that that was a very
interesting idea as well yeah
um but in us like effectively
all of these hypotheses I think do help
explain kind of the the age-related
Paradox as well so like I mentioned
before and and like anyone can observe
uh androgenic alopecia progresses with
age like yeah old people lose like have
less hair than younger people do uh on
average in general and we do also know
that like this does seem to be driven by
Androgen levels like like when you take
drugs to stop DHT conversion
um that does stop the like stop or
significantly slow down the progression
of hair loss
um but like with age you do get
decreases in circulating Androgen levels
and you get decreases in DHT uh
conversion and so like if it was all
just about Androgen stuff you would
expect hair loss to be greater in
younger adults than older adults and and
slow down or stop with age
um but you don't so so if if like
some of the underlying mechanisms do
relate to things like decreasing
subcutaneous fat thickness or decreases
in blood flow or increases in
inflammation like all of those changes
occur with age
um and if those are kind of the
underlying factors causing kind of this
Cascade that ultimately results in hair
loss I think that makes a lot more sense
than it just being about the androgens
per se
um and of these possibilities I I kind
of like I am sympathetic to the
inflammation related one like related to
scalp tension
um
because like another thing that we
observe is that obesity and metabolic
syndrome are also risk factors for
androgenic Alopecia so people with like
insulin resistance obesity metabolic
syndrome tend to have a higher
prevalence of androgenic alopecia a
younger age of onset and an increasing
like progression of of severity of
androgenic alopecia
um and of note uh
like generally those things are
associated with lower testosterone
levels okay but they're also associated
with increased inflammation and like
decreases in blood flow but also
increases in subcutaneous fat thickness
right which kind of throws even more
water on the Turkish guy's idea
um but yeah so I I think that something
related to blood flow or inflammation
like does seem
pretty plausible is kind of what kicks
this whole process off okay but even
independent of that it does seem to be
more intrinsic than anything else
um like there's there's strong
heritability like yeah identical twins
if one goes bald the other one's
probably going to uh it seems to run in
the family uh as it were and there have
also been like studies finding
associations between like genetic
differences in Androgen receptor
polymorphisms and and risk of baldness
so like it does seem to be like mostly
genetic even independent of all of these
other mechanisms like you know maybe
your your mom and dad just have
occipital frontalis muscles that like
predispose the top of your head to
getting inflamed uh and like whatever
like it is what it is
um
and so yeah like
even if like in the worst case scenario
creatine causes hair loss it's probably
not really even causing hair loss like
if you are going to lose your hair
anyways like it might just make you
start losing your hair a little bit
sooner or a little bit faster than you
would have otherwise right like only
about 15 percent of men have little to
no baldness by the age of 70. so like
it's it's coming for all of us or the
vast majority of us and so like yeah
this mug 75 here 75 year olds with a
full head of hair well or rare I mean
we're getting more of them because like
the the hair loss drugs they started
like early to mid 90s
and so like you're do is if
one of the things that I often notice
and a lot of people remark upon when
watching old media is just like how much
older everyone looks yeah and I think
like Seinfeld yeah like I think a lot of
that's Botox I think a lot of it's
plastic surgery but also like you just
see way more bald guys in the 80s than
you do currently and uh yeah yeah that's
because like finasteride I think
launched in 94 like sometime in the mid
90s
um but yeah so people just take hair
loss drugs now yeah it's very popular
yeah I mean you see advertisements for
them everywhere all the time yes
absolutely uh
so you you know what I'm laughing about
yeah let's let's just talk about it uh
hymns and hers commercials oh my God uh
do you want to just like I feel like
I've been talking a lot yeah you want to
talk about these just God forsaken
commercials a little bit sure I mean I
don't think this is particularly useful
but it is funny
um so we get a lot of commercials for
the company's hymns and hers when we're
watching Hulu shows and so basically
it's like
there are a lot of companies like this
where you can kind of fill out an online
quiz or like answer some questions and
you get a prescription from a doctor
it's all online so it makes it really
easy to get prescriptions for different
drugs it's like extremely low touch
telemedicine yes and then it gets
shipped to your house I think they got
really really popular during covid which
makes sense because people didn't want
to leave their house but they still had
needs for medication and now like these
companies have just blown up but the
hers commercials the ones targeted to
women are all about like
anxiety and depression and like needing
medication for that whereas the
commercials for men are just all about
erectile dysfunction and hair loss and
it just is very funny to compare like
one and testosterone okay yeah yeah but
this is very funny to compare like what
they perceive to be the main issues that
the different Sexes face like men are
losing their hair women are depressed
yeah and I mean also just what's being
promoted it's just like hey you want to
live a better life ladies wow I mean
nothing's actually going to get better
in your life so just like take some
drugs to make you feel better and for
the men it's just like look fellas like
I know what's getting you down like it's
it's good to be you but like you don't
want to lose your hair and you want a
hard dick so like look those are the two
problems you're facing and we can solve
them for you and I
just find that very funny yeah it's
funny it's also sad it's really sad
um so yeah uh let's let's get back to to
creatine sure
um so yeah with all of that said kind of
getting into the mechanisms a little bit
more like it is about local conversion
of testosterone to DHT in the scalp not
systemic levels and that conversion
doesn't seem to be just random it seems
to be driven by things like decreases in
Scout blood flow or increases in scalp
inflammation like we don't we still
don't know exactly what's causing that
Cascade to kick off but it seems to be
something kind of in that genre like the
general biochemistry of the scalp is not
happy it's been Disturbed just just for
the listener Greg is just kind of waving
his hands above his head during all of
this just like a wizard yeah whatever
it's fine
um but yeah so essentially just like
there are bad vibes on the top of your
head and that kicks off are there yeah
and that kicks off the DHT conversion
that results in hair loss
um
but yeah so circling back to creatine
creatine doesn't increase free
testosterone levels and that is like the
testosterone that would make it into the
cells to be converted to DHT
um creatine isn't known to decrease skin
blood flow it's not known to decrease
tissue oxygenation it's not known to
increase inflammation it's not known to
cause any changes in subcutaneous fat
morphology
um
and so like all all of the potential
mechanistic underpinnings uh that yeah
that would maybe result in increased
rates of baldness there's no evidence
suggesting that creatine affects any of
that stuff yeah
um
and to be like to be clear it is
possible that it does like there's not
much research on those topics but at the
same time like the same the same could
be said of literally anything you put in
your body like
I don't know how um
I don't know I don't know how rice like
eating rice affects scalp inflammation
or skin blood flow like yeah that's this
yeah that's just not a common thing to
look into for just effects of random
substances you might ingest
um so yeah like we we don't know that
creatine doesn't have those effects but
there's also no evidence suggesting that
it does have those effects
um
and so essentially what we're left with
is we have one study suggesting that
creatine might increase serum DHT levels
but that's irrelevant here yeah like it
it just doesn't matter yeah and there's
no evidence suggesting that creatine
affects any of the things that might
actually kind of more directly
mechanistically affect hair loss yeah do
you think that that's the reason there
hasn't been more research
um what do you mean
if it doesn't seem like there are any
mechanisms for
creatine being associated with hair loss
maybe that's why scientists are like
well we're not going to look into that
because there's not really a mechanism
there
yeah I mean
well so so the thing is like it's
like I don't want to conflate absence of
evidence with evidence of absence yeah
like it it very well could be that
creatine does decrease scalp right right
um but it's it's just not known to yeah
I guess uh and I think more than
anything
the issue is funding because yeah
because like
you know
any
any like so there there are basically
two ways you could run a study to look
at the effects of creatine on ball like
balding or whatever you could either do
a version of a study that's going to be
relatively expensive because you could
use a a kind of small sample size but
you're going to have to do a lot of
biochemistry
um and like all of the chemicals and
equipment and that you need to do
that tend to be quite expensive right or
you could do a study that's going to be
quite expensive because you need to
recruit a large sample Supply them
creatine and observe them for like two
three years like a long enough period of
time to see like directly observed do we
see changes in right in balding rates
um
and so like
you would need
like so that like there's there's going
to be a pretty penny involved in running
one of those studies
um and I'm sure there are researchers
interested in it but like where's the
funding gonna come from like they're
they're probably not going to just like
directly pull that money from
departmental funds because like that is
probably a relatively low priority
um you're certainly not going to get
like Government funding for it because
like
like the they don't care you know yeah
why why would they
um yeah and then with like a supplement
company I I also don't see why they
would want to fund that because the
thing is the first study uh suggesting
that it might increase rmdht levels in
rugby players
it was I believe like an independent
study I don't think it got industry
funding although I I should check that
but I I don't believe it did
um
so if you're a supplement company and
you want to fund a study you're going to
have one of two results either one you
see the increase in DHT again
um which might be bad for product sales
or you don't see the increase in DHT but
then people say like wow this was
industry funded so like we're gonna
trust the first study yeah
um
so yeah and and also like I don't know I
feel like there's very little overlap
between the folks who could actually do
like the really really nitty-gritty
stuff that would be necessary to look
into
like scalp blood flow or like taking
biopsies of the scalp to look at like
directly look at local levels of five
Alpha reductase or DHT levels or
Androgen receptor density and people who
care about creatine you know yeah
um
so yeah yeah there there just hasn't
been follow-up work uh looking at this
yeah
um but yeah so just to
just uh I probably should have put some
of this stuff a little bit earlier in
the outline but one just want to
reiterate the only evidence we have even
potentially linking creatine to hair
loss is a single study looking at its
effects on systemic DHT levels which
again are irrelevant as a further
illustration of that
um there so uh you would take drugs that
are kind of similar to hair loss drugs
if you have benign prostate growth
because well you wouldn't but I I
potentially would uh because DHT
promotes prostate growth but just as
like further evidence that dht's actions
do seem to be like mostly autocone and
paracrine not systemic
um I'm going to link a study in the show
notes looking at the effects of
transdermal DHT treatment for two years
on prostate growth so basically like
rubbing yeah or I think it was a patch
just like a that would allow DHT to
diffuse through the skin so like men in
the study used transdermal DHT for two
years and it was enough DHT to increase
their blood DHT levels tenfold and it
had no effect on prostate growth damn
like the DHT causing prostate growth is
DHT produced in the prostate right much
like the DHT causing hair loss is DHT
produced in the scalp
um
and uh
yeah so I mean that that just about does
it uh
a lot of stuff there
uh all of which is to say like
we can't confidently say that creatine
doesn't cause hair loss but again the
same can be said for nearly anything you
put in your body and the only study that
people might point to to suggest that
creatine would cause hair loss like for
the fifth time is looking at something
completely irrelevant like serum DHT
levels do not matter like it's it's not
it's not just that like oh the bass line
was a little bit low in the creatine
condition or like oh it's within the
normal range like none of that
matters like even even if we did
absolutely know that creatine caused an
increase in blood DHT levels that it
that still doesn't give us reason to
suspect it would cause baldness like
like we would need to see changes in
scalp DHT
um
so it's wild though that this one study
is kind of what has fueled all of this
speculation about it oh for sure like
whenever I was researching for this
episode and just kind of
reading around like there are so many
articles specifically set to answer the
question of does creatine cause hair
loss because it is such a popular
question
um and so I could go through a couple of
those yeah yeah yeah so I mean almost
all the articles I read about it talk
about how creatine likely does not cause
hair loss so just to give a couple
examples Men's Health has an article
called don't blame creatine for hair
loss that says creatine remains a
Perpetual Target for rumors and
misconceptions among the most powerful
that creatine causes hair loss the myth
stemmed from a single early study where
the results have yet to be replicated
and they note that research remains
ongoing and quote Jose Antonio who
published a paper about creatine myths
and is quoted in almost every single
article about this like he really went
on the full media tour good for him
but he said the current body of evidence
does not indicate that creatine causes
hair loss or boldness nice
um Women's Health had something similar
saying in their creatine guide if you've
heard on the Grapevine that creatine
could cause hair loss fret not it's BS
and they quote uh physiologist and
nutrition scientist who says there's no
existing literature to show that hair
loss is a side effect of creatine
supplementation and a Sports Illustrated
article also states that creatine
supplement supplementation doesn't cause
hair loss incites the Jose Antonio paper
again nice so I when I was like looking
through this
I was confused because
you know
so many people ask this question so many
people think that creatine does cause
hair loss but then when you actually
look into it if you look at any of these
articles even from mainstream press
like they're all saying the same thing
and obviously they're not telling the
whole story like you were able to do
here but they should be assuaging
people's fears and it just seems to not
be working yeah yeah I think that um
I don't know I think I think a lot of it
is just kind of like
related to the general concept of loss
aversion yeah like it
like people tend to be generally risk
averse and
um what so one I think that there's a
pretty common cultural image of what
like gym guys look like yeah and it's
oftentimes bald people
um that's true like if you think like
big muscly folks oftentimes you're just
no hair just completely hairless yeah
um and I think I mean I think a lot of
that's because of steroids yes but uh
yeah so really just like bodybuilding
culture too just like you're gonna shave
your body for the stage yeah so like
shaver head too yeah and so I one I
think I think a lot of people already
kind of have this idea that like
something these folks are doing is
causing hair loss yeah
um and yeah like there is this this one
again totally irrelevant study on
creatine that unless you dig into the
the biochemistry enough like I I can see
why it might make some people concerned
um
and then like yeah it's like most people
don't want to lose their hair and I I
think that just the suggestion that
something might cause hair loss is
enough that like even even if you
accept that the balance of evidence
suggests that like it probably doesn't
or at least there's not strong reason to
to think that would just that that just
the fact that that idea got planted in
your mind is still enough to scare
people off of it and maybe repeat to
other folks like yeah it might cause
hair loss you know yeah yeah there is
actually
um a article about it on hymns.com we
just talked about them but they say
um there's no definitive scientific
evidence linking hair loss and creatine
supplements but then they say the
converse of that is also true there's no
definitive scientific evidence that
rules out hair loss as a potential side
effect of creatine supplements so I
think that that's like which is also
true it's true but I think that that's
what people get really hung up on yeah
and that's why like when they see
anecdotes and there are so many
anecdotes on like Reddit and I like even
went through all the old like
bodybuilder dot com forums like looking
for when people were talking about
creatine and hair loss and they've been
doing that since this study came out
like a lot of people say this has
happened to me and it ruined my life
basically and that's really
uh like people people really take that
seriously like they're really scared of
that when they see somebody else saying
it yeah no I mean I
you know I I see where they're coming
from yeah and the thing is like
a couple of things one is
once people have in their head that like
something causes some bad outcome what
they're going to want is evidence to the
contrary right and generally it's not
sufficient to say the evidence the
positive evidence to support your
position is very weak generally they
want evidence that like direct evidence
that that thing is not true yes but in
that case like you're you're asking like
like it's it's much easier to
demonstrate something than to like
conclusively demonstrate the Opposites
yeah of the thing yeah
um because like yeah if creatine caused
hair loss
it would be pretty straightforward like
a
you know it would be easy to run a study
for a while and say like oh hey look
people taking creatine their hair is
getting thinner yeah but when it comes
to like fully ruling something out then
it's a lot
tougher because a similar study could
find no relationship but people might
criticize the funding source or say like
ah it didn't run long enough or oh the
dosage was too low or like any number of
other things
um and yeah like I don't know there it
it's a matter of burden of proof right
like there's no there's there's not
it's just a topic where there's not much
evidence period right and so like
there's not evidence to support it but
by the same token there's not evidence
to refute it yeah so and that just
leaves a huge vacuum and it can just be
filled up with you know people just
speculating based on what their friends
and what the Bros at the gym says for
sure and I mean most people who
experience hair loss when they start
taking creatine are probably people who
are gonna start losing their hair
anyways yeah and then they just blame it
on Creatine because they've heard this
thing and they're just kind of more
tuned into it
um like maybe you weren't noticing your
hair falling out in the shower even if
it was before and now you start because
you took creatine and you're afraid of
it happening yeah I I think I think
that's a lot of it I I think that one
it's it's a matter of like a lot of
people get into lifting when they're
in their like early to mid 20s to maybe
like early to mid 30s yeah which if
you're gonna lose your hair that's
probably around when it's gonna start
like some people start losing their hair
in their teens and boy howdy do I feel
for them but like that's that's a small
mind you just gotta own it at that point
yeah yeah and they're they're also very
few people who are going to lose a lot
of their hair that haven't started
losing any into their 50s like usually
if you're going to lose your hair 20s or
30s is around when it starts it's gonna
start happening yeah 20s or 30s is also
around when a lot of people a lot of
people start getting into resistance
training or getting into it enough to
start taking supplements yeah and also
probably just kind of two
their bodies more too yeah
yeah because you you can you can treat
your body like a rental when you're 19.
but yeah you start getting into your
late 20s early 30s and you're like yeah
let's let's start paying attention to
stuff yeah yeah um so yeah I think
that's part of it another thing is
um
yeah like like you said I I think that
there's a tendency and and we talked
about this on the last episode as well
there's a tendency for
um making assumptions about causal
connections to things that are only
temporally Associated
um and what you choose as the causal
factor is largely just based on like
what you've heard floating around
um so like uh
like we we talked about this in relation
to like headaches and aspartame in the
last episode uh or or just like any
number of things in aspartame where it's
just like a lot of the people
attribute to Aspartame is probably not
caused by aspartame but you've heard
somewhere that aspartame can cause this
thing you experience the thing aspartame
didn't cause the thing but you assume
that it did right and I I think that's a
lot of it for creatine like I think I
think a lot of people probably don't
really think that creatine causes hair
loss but then yeah they start getting
into their mid-20s early 30s start
losing a little bit of hair and they're
like ah I started losing my hair
well I've heard this thing about
creatine I guess that's what did it
right but it's also like well your dad
and all of your uncles are bald so like
maybe it's not the creatine yeah
um yeah I I suspect that's a lot of it
yeah but again it is also possible that
it causes hair loss yes but it it's just
simply the case that there is
no direct evidence now that it does in
the study people cite about DHT is again
irrelevant
serum levels serum levels of DHT don't
influence hair loss
let's move on okay
okay so next
um
let's see so the the next thing I'm
going to talk about I figure I should
ask you about this before I actually
bring up the topic okay so Lindsay have
you come across people discussing our
articles discussing how creatine
actually
uh Works to increase muscle growth
um I
think that when I read it my brain just
kind of shuts off but I think like
um
my understanding of what those articles
are saying is that like it it just
provides that additional energy which
allows you to do like a couple more reps
and then just being able to do a couple
more reps is what is causing the
um
whatever muscle gain or strength gain
that you're experiencing from taking
creatine okay so I was hoping that's
what you would say okay good because
that is the common answer you'll hear
and I think that's wrong oh uh so it it
does do that but I don't think that is
the actual way that it increases muscle
growth
um so yeah just just to expand a little
bit on what you said like when you ask
people like oh hey like creatine
increases muscle growth but like how
does it do that the typical answer
you'll get is what we talked about up
top with the the mechanism of how
creatine influences performance
basically you take creatine it increases
your phosphocreatine levels that gives
you a route for faster ATP resynthesis
especially during high intensity
exercise so that uh like increases
strength endurance increases anaerobic
performance a little bit just lets you
work a little bit harder do a few more
rights
um and people say like oh hey like
that's that is how it uh oh like allows
you to increase muscle growth it
increases performance therefore you can
increase the stimulus you place on your
muscles therefore they grow more yeah a
secondary mechanism that you'll
sometimes see discussed uh relates to
how creatine can act as a weak buffer so
creatine can can basically like soak up
uh some hydrogen ions which is like what
directly causes acidosis like a drop in
PH in the muscle and also uh when like
after after ATP is used they're like
inorganic phosphates kind of floating
floating around in the muscle and a
combination of acidosis and elevated
free phosphate levels seem to like
directly and mechanistically reduce
muscle contractility and decrease
exercise performance and since creatine
can kind of soak up some of those
hydrogen ions and some of those free
phosphates that should improve
performance as well specifically like
anore performance what does acidosis
mean uh just like your muscles are kind
of acidic the pH level is lower okay
um so yeah those are those are the two
things you'll often hear discussed in
the model is essentially creatine does
these things that that can acutely
increase exercise performance and that
increase in performance increases the
stimulus the increase in stimulus is
what
then allows creatine supplementation to
increase muscle growth or strength gains
and like I said I don't think that is
how it works primarily and the reason I
don't think that's how it works
is that there are other supplements that
work the same way so there are plenty of
supplements that primarily work by
increasing strength endurance so you
have like caffeine you have citrulline
malate you have bicarbonate you have
beta-alanine you have a few others but
like those are those are the big ones
and those aren't the ones that are like
on the top tier with creatine right like
and they all
in terms of performance during training
have effects that are comparable in size
to creatine okay and it's the same types
of performances that are improved like
it's mostly high intensity performance
or like strength endurance like
anaerobic performance type of stuff
um and there are also longitudinal
studies looking at the effects of those
supplements on muscle growth and they
don't increase muscle growth
um
and so I don't think the effects of
creatine on performance are the primary
reason that creatine influences muscle
growth okay like essentially
there are there are a couple ways you
could look at it and this is not the
episode to go like way far down the
rabbit hole of just like a mechanistic
accounting of hypertrophy signaling oh
my goodness um like one one easy way to
think about it I guess is that you know
if the most reps you can get with a
particular load is say 10 reps then in
general as you get a little bit closer
to failure the stimulus will tend to
increase if you if you for just some
other reason like let's say let's say
you've done some cardio and like your
general endurance has increased and now
you can do 12 reps with the same load uh
if you but but not you know not due to
your resistance training just like the
kind of your your local metabolic stuff
in that muscle has improved yeah
um if you now just stop at 10 reps that
will probably be a a smaller stimulus
than it would have been when 10 reps was
the most you could have done and now to
get the same stimulus you need to do
those 12 reps that you're now capable of
doing yes and I think that with
supplements that acutely increase
performance I kind of think that's
what's going on it's like you can maybe
get a couple more reps but now also to
get the same stimulus for adaptation you
need to do those couple extra reps
you're working just as hard either way
right yeah um so yeah I think that's
kind of what's going on but there are
other like mechanisms by which creatine
could influence muscle growth so there
there was a review paper by chillibbeck
and colleagues that was published in
2017 I believe like everything else it
will be linked in the show notes and
figure two in that paper
um just kind of sketches out these
mechanisms and it's it's open access so
anyone should be able to to look at this
um but essentially like of the potential
mechanisms listed in this paper by which
creatine could influence muscle growth
the like Direct effects on
phosphocreatine and Exercise capacity
are only like one of the five things
listed
um and most of the other things are
things that are kind of like more known
to be like directly related to
hypertrophy okay so for instance
creatine supplementation affects
myogenic regulatory factors such as and
this probably won't mean anything to you
or most people listening perfect uh myf5
myod myogenin and mrf4
potentially due to its effects on igf-1
or potentially through some other
mechanism and yeah like you don't need
to know what any of that means but okay
essentially what myogenic regulatory
factors are
are things uh
not exactly like but similar to what I
talked about with how steroid hormones
work where essentially they bind to a
receptor go to the nucleus and directly
influence Gene transcription okay
myogenic regulatory factors aren't
exactly like that but they're kind of
like that like they're they're these
little there's the they're these little
guys these little hormones these little
proteins that do through various
mechanisms influence Gene transcription
okay and I mean ultimately that's that's
the name of the game when it comes to
building muscle like people talk about
like ah tension metabolic stress
whatever but like directly and most
acutely what what you need is you need
something to go to the nucleus of a
muscle cell and say hey let's uh let's
transcribe this Gene that says let's
build more actin or myosin proteins
right and then that needs to go to a
ribosome that will actually build those
proteins and then yeah like that that's
how that's how protein is synthesized
like that's how size in a muscle is
accrued
um and so ultimately like myogenic
regulatory factors are like more
directly working on that process to
directly influence Gene Tran Gene
transcription in a way that promotes net
anabolism that's cool yeah and so I I
think that's the primary thing that
creativity is doing
uh creatine also might decrease
myostatin levels uh do you do you know
about myostatins I feel like you do I've
heard that word before I cannot give you
a description of of it though I'll give
you a hint I talked about it quite a bit
on our trip to Belgium oh yeah it has to
do with the cows yeah the really
muscular cows Belgian Blues yeah bully
whippets yeah like there's something
there's something about them about their
myostatin levels that are either like
too high or too low or something too low
too low yeah and like they just get
super jacked like they look insane yeah
so if if you have like no myostatin you
get dummy thick like super jacked uh
myostatin essentially what it does is it
uh reduces satellite Cell Activation and
so like one of the things that happens
is muscles grow is you have these stem
cells that are kind of floating around
the muscle fibers called called
satellite cells and they need to be
activated and then proliferate and then
mature and then they donate their their
nuclei to the muscle and that becomes
more myonuclei and like as fibers get
bigger and bigger and bigger they need
more and more nuclei to like have
sufficient transcriptional capacity is
is what it's called just to like
be able to tell enough ribosomes to
produce enough proteins to keep the
fiber the size it currently is
um so yeah like myostatin generally
promotes
smaller muscle fibers or like decreases
in rates of growth due to slowing down
that process of satellite Cell
Activation and myonuclear accretion and
so creatine
reduces myostatin levels to some extent
so that okay that could also be a way
that it's getting you closer to the cows
yeah uh so that that could also be like
again a more direct way that it
influences muscle growth uh other than
just like improving performance yeah and
then finally uh creatine can also buffer
free radicals which we are not getting
into redox biochemistry in this episode
that is too big a can of worms but
essentially like there's there's some
level of oxidative stress that is good
there is some level that is bad and like
having a positive response to exercise
largely like a important part of it
seems to be like
kind of finding the happiness around
there yeah
um so like a a great example here is
like high levels of antioxidant intake
or
um
I mean I guess inflammation's slightly
different but it's it's related it's
like taking NSAIDs for instance
um for younger adults that reduces
muscle growth like it it reduces
oxidative stress too much so you don't
get
um the the Adaptive response you're
looking for for older adults that have
higher levels of inflammation those
things might actually increase muscle
growth a little bit because it'll bring
it back to like a happy medium yeah like
they're further along that bell curve so
like bringing it back down brings you
back towards the optimal levels
um so yeah like creatine's ability to
buffer free radicals it's probably not
particularly relevant to how it might
influence muscle growth in younger
adults but maybe maybe in older adults
um
but yeah so I I think those are the more
likely mechanisms for how creatine like
directly influences muscle growth if it
was just about acute performance you
would expect caffeine citrulline malate
beta-alanine like several other things
to improve hypertrophy in the same way
and to the same extent that you see with
creatine and you just don't so I don't
think the effects on performance are the
primary factor uh contributing to to
creatine's effects on muscle growth I do
think it's mostly the myogenic
regulatory factors with maybe the
effects on myostatin and maybe the
effects on buffering free radicals
playing secondary roles and then if the
effects on acute performance are
relevant I think I think the magnitude
of that effect is is pretty small yeah
why do you think that that
misunderstanding has kind of spread
around so much about like the more
simplistic definite or the more
simplistic explanation
um
oh man
I think one
I think one is like firm for marketing
purposes simple explanations tend to
work better
um
like yeah and the explanation is correct
right it's just like there's other
things that are just like more directly
impacting yeah the the effects on
performance like that that is legit like
that is a thing that happens
um and so yeah like I I think that it
just feels intuitive to someone to be
like oh hey like muscle volume is
important for for growth this thing
helps you increase your volume by uh
improving ATP turnover and like maybe
reducing acidosis a little bit
um so yeah it helps you perform better
that helps you grow more whatever
I I think that that makes for a good
sales pitch yeah two
is just kind of the basic biochemistry
of creatine was known way before most of
the kind of effects on myogenic
regulatory factors or myostatin or
whatever was known yeah like we've we've
known how creatine Works since the 60s
right like we know we've known how it
improves ATP recycling I think the I
think the buffering stuff I think that
may have been the 80s but like we knew
that before
uh before people actually started taking
creatine so I think that that was
probably the most plausible explanation
at the time
um and so I think there's a bit of
inertia associated with it
um
and yeah like I
I think that those are the two biggest
that makes sense yeah
uh okay
the next thing this is
this is I believe a myth that has
resulted in the attempt to bust a myth
so man uh an exception
yes so among like like quote unquote
evidence-based Fitness folks who are
generally pro-creatine you will
sometimes
encounter the claim that like uh people
say creatine causes bloating or fluid
retention and and these folks will push
back and say no it doesn't no it doesn't
like you absorb it it goes into your
muscles it increases intramuscular
creatine levels intramuscular hydration
and so the increase you see on on the
scale is just about like increased fluid
content in the in the muscles like it's
not actually causing bloating or fluid
retention
and I think that that's mostly wrong or
at least partially wrong so have you
come across the claim that creatine
causes bloating or like when you've
tried it previously did you notice that
for yourself I don't know if I noticed
it for myself I'm bloated all the time
because I just have all kinds of weird
food issues so who knows if it was from
the creatine but in terms of like what
I've come across
um on the internet I mean I mentioned
that like in the macro Factor group like
a lot of people talk about weight gain
when they first start using creatine and
like feeling more bloated
um I don't know is that the same thing
like the weight gain thing in the
bloating thing
um like they're they're related
essentially people who are pro-bloating
would say oh you're up two pounds
because you're bloated and people
uh against that idea would say that's
just two pounds of additional like
creatine and fluid retention in your
muscles but that's that's not bloating
okay I've heard more of like the two
pounds because of the creatine and like
fluid retention gotcha
um so yeah like the there is
there is this common claim that creatine
causes bloating and people who are
pro-creatine will push back against that
and say again it's not bloating it's
just increasing muscle creatine con
concentrations some fluid comes along
with that so like you are seeing the
number on the scale go up but that
that's just because of fluid content in
your muscles themselves
uh and the thing is like the math just
doesn't work out for that and so this is
this is a this is a math section and I
apologize okay maybe maybe an audio
medium is not the best for this but it
let's give it it's also I think pretty
straightforward okay
Okay so
muscle concentration of creatine in
people who don't supplement with
creatine is about 120 millimoles per
kilogram of dry mass of the muscle so if
you take like a biopsy and and dry it
out and then just look at the contents
of the powder the concentration is about
120 millimoles per kilogram of dry Mass
okay when people take creatine like when
they when they supplement creatine and
fully saturate their muscle creatine
stores that seems to top out at a
concentration about of about 160
millimoles per kilogram of dry Mass with
supplementation
okay so that's the starting point
then muscle is about three quarters
water so when we go from dry Mass to wet
mass we're essentially dividing the
concentrations in the dry mass by three
okay or by four I mean because the the
dry mass is about a quarter of the total
mass
so without creatine supplementation
you're seeing concentrations of about 30
millimoles per kilogram of wet mass and
about 40 millimoles per kilogram with
supplementation okay following me so far
difference of about one-third or about
10 millimoles per kilogram
all right so now we get into everyone's
favor from high school chemistry
Stoichiometry
um
yeah you did it I don't remember it was
like converting molar masses to like
actual grams and
maybe Avogadro's number that sounds
familiar because yeah it's it's no one
no one uses this in day-to-day life this
is this is a totally fine thing to have
forgotten
um
anyway so the molar mass of creatine is
that that is the mass of a single
creatine molecule okay multiplied by
Avogadro's number so like what is that
like six I I don't what is it I think
it's like 6.0 to me I think it's 6.02
times 10 to the 23rd or something oh wow
yeah just pull that out just Google it
I'm
I I feel I think that's wrong but close
enough whatever so when you multiply
is
I'm I'm getting sidetracked whatever you
don't need here here's what it looks
like yes 6.02 times 10 to the 23rd hell
yeah I'm no one has ever said that so
excitedly I'm very proud of myself for
remembering that uh and you have a
mental illness I I know I do anyway so
the molar mass of creatine is
131.13 grams per mole so if we're
looking at a change in creatine of 10
millimoles that is uh
131.13 times 10 divided by a thousand
since it's millimoles to get how many
actual grams of creatine we're talking
about and it's uh one point it's about
1.3 grams of creatine okay in total
um per kilogram of muscle
so that that is how much additional
creatine per kilogram of muscle you are
storing after creatine supplementation
when you go from 120 to 160 uh
millimoles per kilogram of dry mass that
seems like very little yeah it's it's
not a ton
so yeah uh if if you took just like 2.2
pounds of human muscle tissue pre and
post creatine supplementation you'd see
about one one and a half grams of
additional creatine in that 2.2 pounds
of muscle
okay and then creatine like a lot of
things is stored in the muscle with
about four grams of water sticking to it
like a gram of creatine is stored with
about four grams of water
um so that is a total increase in Mass
attributable to creatine
of about 5.3 grams per kilogram of
muscle or in other words an increase in
like total muscle mass directly
attributable to creatine plus water of
about 0.53 percent
okay so then the next step
in an untrained male uh
you tend to start with about 30 to 35
kilograms of skeletal muscle mass okay
um I think people assume it's a lot
higher I think a lot of people kind of
assume that skeletal muscle comprises
like most of your total fat-free mass or
lean mass but it it's about half in in
general so yeah if someone's like 80
kilos like 20 body fat
um about 40 of their body mass would be
muscle mass
um and so yeah that that's like 30 35
kilos for for most untrained males okay
um
and so when you
when you multiply that out like a 0.53
percent increase in Mass for that amount
of muscle mass you're looking at a total
increase in body mass directly
attributable to creatine plus water in
muscle tissue of about 160 to 185 grams
which is not much at all
um what would that be like three and a
half to
like .35 to 0.4 pounds something like
that uh not much at all yeah and so
we also know creatine supplementation
causes an acute increase in body mass of
like one one and a half percent or like
around a kilo around two pounds
so it's increasing body mass by about a
kilo it's increasing uh like muscle
weight due to increases in creatine and
water in the muscle uh of like 160 to
185 grams
means that only about 15 to 20 percent
of the total weight increase when people
take creatine is directly attributable
to creatine uptake and Associated Water
uptake in the muscle itself yeah the
other 80 85 percent
I don't know what is it I don't
know
um but you know the kind of catch-all
terms of like bloating or like General
fluid retention
I feel like those aren't like terrible
labels to put on it because there's not
another label you could put on it it
seems like I mean I do suspect a lot of
it is just like digestive tract contents
and like an increase in water in the
digestive tract because especially if
you're doing a loading phase maybe
you've like fully saturated the creatine
Transporters in your gut and so like you
just have like extra undigested stuff
and your intestines will just dilute
that down with water
um maybe some maybe some of some of it's
just like hanging out in your blood and
you get like an increase in like a small
increase in blood volume as a result
maybe it's going to some other tissues
like I I sincerely don't know how to
account for the other like 80 85 percent
of that but the mass that is directly
attributable to creatine and water and
the muscle is a pretty small minority of
the total mass increases that we observe
when people take creatine yeah
um so yeah like people people who who
try to bust the myth that creatine
causes bloating I think they're more so
the ones contributing to the myth like I
think creatine properly does cause a bit
of bloating like the the acute increases
in body mass that are attributable to
creatine supplementation are not fully
attributable to increases in muscle mass
so
yeah the other 80 85 percent don't know
what it is but I I think just bloating
fluid retention terms like that are
probably decent ways to describe it yeah
and does that kind of even out after
you've been taking it for a couple weeks
uh like it doesn't go away but it
flattens out yeah okay like you'll if
you do like a loading phase or whatever
like your your body mass might increase
by about a kilo in three or four days
and then it just kind of like stays
elevated at about a kilo higher than it
was
um until you stop taking creatine and
then you get a small decrease
um
you know I I think it probably does also
decrease a little bit I don't really
know but yeah whatever okay
okay uh the last little myth I wanted to
address is actually a pretty a pretty
recent myth
um but before I say what it is I just
want to ask lens have you come across
any information or discussion about
creatine dosing like if I just asked you
how much creatine should people take uh
about about what would about what would
you say I think the number that I see is
five grams per day
um but I've also like I also know about
the loading phase that a lot of people
do in which it's like significantly
higher I don't know what that number
usually is I mean we've been talking
about it so it's like 20 25 probably
um and then the
most recent time that I saw somebody
talking about a much higher dose was on
the Instagram post that we had for your
creatine research Spotlight a couple
weeks ago and somebody was saying that
they take a much much higher dose
specifically for the mental benefits
like the brain effects that you can get
from taking creatine which I know
nothing about
um but I think that if somebody's doing
that then they might take like
20 grams per day on an ongoing basis
yeah uh have you seen people promoting
like kind of Maintenance doses exceeding
five grams for like muscle effects I
don't think so okay well that that's
good that's good
um
so yeah you're you're correct that
people do take more than five so first
you're correct that kind of the typical
recommendation is about five grams a day
um you are also correct that people will
sometimes take more as a loading dose
this feels like a quiz
no it's it's not like you I'm nervous if
I was correct or not you're you were
correct across the board okay I'm I'm
just reiterating thank you for
information retention for the audience
okay
um and yeah you're you're correct that
if you want some of the potential like
mental or cognitive benefits of creatine
supplementation which is beyond the
scope of this episode The the research
suggests that like you probably need
more than five grams a day for that um
but yeah the stock recommendation for a
maintenance dose of creatine for the
muscle related effects is like three to
five grams a day
but there is a
there's an idea floating around that
seems to currently be on the upswing in
popularity that lifters like serious
lifters actually need to take more than
five grams a day
um
and that yeah that that most people are
under dosing creatine and that if you're
if you're not noticing the effects of
the creatine you're taking it's because
you're too jacked because you're a
serious lifter and you need to take more
oh my God so
to start with like
if you're not noticing effects of
creatine supplementation it's it's
especially if you're an omnivore or
since these people exist now
carnivores
um it's probably just because you're
getting like a supplemental amount of
creatine just from the food you're
eating like most of the creatine in the
human diet comes from meat consumption
so like the average person like the
average omnivore consumes like one one
and a half grams of creatine a day from
the meat they consume if you
if you have like a protein Target that's
like two three times higher than what
the typical person is aiming for because
you're a serious lifter and you're
getting most of that from animal
products it's very possible that you're
already consuming three to five grams of
creatine a day just from the meat you're
eating yeah
um and so then yeah like you you might
already have muscle creatine stores that
are like 160 millimoles per kilogram of
dry weight right so it's like
supplemental creatine is not going to do
anything yeah
um
but the the idea that most lifters are
under dosing
um comes from the fact and like this is
fairly understandable that like a lot of
the early research on Creatine dosing
was performed on untrained subjects who
are less muscular than serious lifters
and you're trying to increase muscle
creatine levels so if someone has 50
more muscle mass
theoretically and practically like this
is probably true they probably would
need to consume about 50 more protein
than the person with way less muscle
um but what I think a lot of people
don't realize is the common kind of
stock recommendation of five grams a day
is already a better safe than sorry
recommendation that is already
comfortably more than most people
actually need like two to three grams a
day is probably sufficient for the vast
majority of people including a lot of
lifters so
um
I I think I think what's currently
driving the present surge in this is
there was a recent episode of The
huberman Lab podcast where he's he where
Andrew huberman said he uses 10 grams a
day for for the muscle effects I believe
like not specifically for the cognitive
effects it's like 10 grams a day for
cognitive effects that would probably be
a little underdosed but he's like yeah
like I'm a serious lifter I'm jacked
need more creatine 10 grams a day a lot
of people take his his recommendations
seriously so that seems to be the thing
like driving the current Surge and
interest in higher creatine doses this
is something that kind of Ebbs and flows
like I've in my time kind of consuming
Fitness content I've seen multiple waves
of people being interested in consuming
more creatine saying like ah five grams
might be too little for serious lifters
so yeah I assume this will be Evergreen
like this once uh once the the wave from
the huberman episode subsides like this
will come back in a couple years like it
always makes that makes sense yeah
um so yeah let's let's talk about where
the kind of like dosing information for
for creatine comes from and how we can
be fairly confident that five grams a
day is already more than sufficient for
almost everybody okay so there was a so
there was a lot of like older research
on Creatine dosing but probably the best
and most relevant for our discussion
here is a classic
1996 paper from Holtman and colleagues
nice published in the prestigious
Journal of Applied physiology and
um this was a study with
so there there were three arms to the
study one of the arms was looking at
like rates of creatine concentration
decreases after people stop using it not
going to talk about that one much like
when I said it takes about a month for
creatine levels to go back to Baseline
after supplementation uh that's what
that's based on like they had one group
that just went through a loading phase
stopped taking it look to see how long
it took to get back to Baseline seemed
to take about four weeks
there were two other studies that were
like written up in this paper
one of them
um
was looking at muscle creatine
concentrations after a loading phase a
six day loading phase where people took
20 grams of creatine per day okay
followed by 30 days of taking 2 grams a
day
and then the other experiment was people
just taking three grams a day every day
for 28 days nice and both groups
achieved the same muscle creatine
concentrations around 150 160 millimoles
per kilogram of dry Mass
um and and that's noteworthy because
like the loading phase itself like that
definitely saturates muscle creatine
levels so you do the loading phase you
get up to that 150 160 and then if 2
grams a day is sufficient to maintain
that yeah that that's strong evidence
that it's sufficient to maintain maximal
concentrations because you know the
loading phase got you to those maximal
concentrations interesting so does
but if you wanted to you could just do
creatine like as a loading phase every
couple months and then just if you're
eating enough to get two grams per day
that you could sustain that that's a
good question
to which I don't have a good answer
sorry
um no I mean like I think if you're
already
like if the typical person is eating
like one one and a half grams of
creatine a day I think that if you're
already getting closer to like three
three four grams in your diet I don't
think you need I suspect you probably
don't need you donate the loading phase
I suspect you don't need to use creatine
yeah yeah like you you probably have
like well I was saying like if you are
eating like more like two grams per day
um I mean if if you're trying to keep
your muscle creatine levels absolutely
topped off
um
I don't know why you would do that
because like even if you weren't fully
back to like 120 uh millimoles per
kilogram or whatever
uh you're you are going to be you are
going to have lower creatine levels at
the end of that month yeah that you
would have at the start
um and also just senses loading dose is
like four or five times as much creatine
as like a maintenance dose
taking a maintenance dose every day for
that month would cost you the same as
doing the loading phase for a week every
month so like I don't know why you would
do that but like okay just a theoretical
I guess yeah you it's not a bad question
to ask but like practically I think it
would just be worse in all regards
perfect
so I asked that question so that you
won't do that listener perfect
um but yeah so essentially like the
loading phase gives you a point of
comparison like it gets you to Max
concentrations so if you don't see a
decrease during that phase of taking two
grams a day that lets you know that 2
grams was enough to maintain Max
concentrations and then with comparison
to the other group as well the group
just taking three grams a day without a
loading phase they got up to the same
muscle creatine concentrations as the
group that did the loading phase which
again is pretty strong evidence that the
three grams a day was sufficient to
achieve maximum muscle creatine levels
how long did it take for them to match
um they were pretty close after 21 days
and they were they were there at 28.
okay yeah
um so yeah both of those strategies led
to the same maximum muscle creatine
concentrations and the two grams a day
was sufficient to sustain the the
creatine levels
and so these were not totally untrained
subjects but they were
um
I I believe I believe the the authors
noted that like they yeah here's the the
direct quote all subjects undertook some
form of regular exercise but none was
highly trained so these weren't like
super serious lifters
um but like two to three grams did seem
like about enough for them okay
um the average body mass in the loading
phase followed by two grams maintenance
group was about 85 kilos uh it was about
75 kilos for just the straight three
gram a day group and so the two gram a
day maintenance dose in the first group
worked out to about
0.023 grams per kilogram of body mass
and for the three gram a day group that
worked out to about
0.039 grams per kilogram and so like one
of the one of like the the criticisms
you'll see from people saying ah you
need to take way more creatine as
they'll say like the five gram A Day
recommendation isn't scale to body mass
but but a a recommendation you'll
frequently see in the research is
actually scale at the body mass and it's
largely based on this paper and it's
just 0.03 grams per kilogram because
that's like in between kind of the what
what we knew to be the sufficient
maintenance dose in the one group and
what we knew to be a dose that led to
maximum concentrations in the other
group so yeah like 0.03 grams per
kilogram is already a body weight scaled
recommendation that you'll frequently
see
and so
yeah if you're like an untrained person
who's like 70 kilos that's like 154
pounds 0.03 grams per kilogram would
mean that about two 2.1 grams of
creatine per day should be sufficient to
maximize muscle creatine levels and
maintain that maximum concentration
if you're like 100 kilos like 220 3
grams a day should be plenty if you're
like 150 kilos like 330 pounds four and
a half grams a day should be plenty yeah
so that 5 gram recommendation is like
that's all right that's enough yeah like
that that's an extremely better safe
than sorry yes recommendation already
um and this largely makes sense so
with creatine intake or creatine
supplementation
you're essentially just trying to more
than replace urinary losses of
creatinine so in solution creatine will
will spontaneously break down to
something called creatinine which is uh
kind of kind of a byproduct I guess but
like it's it's just what creatine will
break down to in solution like if you if
you just had water and you dissolved a
bunch of creatine into it about half of
it would become creatinine if you just
let it sit for months and like reach
equilibrium yeah but like the rate at
which it decomposes to creatinine is
pretty slow
and um so the the Holtman study also
measured
um like rates of of creatinine excretion
in urine and it was about 10 millimoles
per day which like given the molar mass
of creatinine is like 1.1 grams per day
uh looking at some other just sources so
this was uh the University of Rochester
Medical Center they say that the typical
rate of creatinine excretion in urine is
about 0.8 to 1.8 grams per day in men
and about 0.6 to 1.6 grams per day in
women and essentially like that is how
creatine leaves your body it leaves your
body as creatinine and so if your total
creatine intake exceeds creatinine
excretion you should have a net
accretion of creatine like you should be
maximizing muscle creatine levels with
with like a bit of a a bit of an
adjustment uh so like the molar mass of
creatine is like a little bit heavier
than creatinine so like your creatine
intake does need to be a little bit
higher than your creatinine excretion
but essentially like
Yes somewhere in the neighborhood of
like two grams a day of creatine intake
should be sufficient to exceed
creatinine excretion
um
and that also kind of makes sense
because like the typical rates of
creatinine excretion are pretty similar
to like normal creatine intake in the
general population so like that that is
the deterministic factor like the the
concentration of creatine that you
achieve in your muscles is based on that
balance between creatine intake and
creatinine excretion and so like you
should kind of expect creatinine
excretion to more or less match creatine
intake
um
so yeah like like theoretically since
that is the the discriminating Factor
just like how much creatinine are you
excreting that you need to replace with
more creatine
um if like creatine intake already
matches creatinine excretion like maybe
even taking a gram of creatine per day
would take a long time to fully saturate
your muscle creatine stores but it might
be sufficient like in one and a half two
grams a day again for for most people
would probably actually be a dose that
it might take two or three months but
would still saturate your muscle
creatine stores and keep them saturated
um so a possible response to this from
someone who is Big on on Creatine mega
dosing
is that well sure but like
again the people in the study weren't
Elite strength athletes and it may not
be appropriate to scale to body mass in
the first place which like 0.03 grams
per kilogram of body scale into body
mass But ultimately we care about muscle
creatine levels and so it might make
more sense to scale to muscle mass
um and we can do that it's easy so again
like these were fairly typical guys in
the Holtman study we're going to assume
they had a fairly typical amount of
muscle mass about 32 kilos it's like
three grams a day is like about
.094 grams per kilogram of skeletal
muscle and about 2 grams a day would be
about
0.063 or so grams per kilogram of
skeletal muscle so like let's let's use
those as our baselines and try to figure
out
if that's kind of the dosing window
we're looking at how much creatine would
outrageously jacked people need to
consume if we're scaling to muscle mass
yeah and so there's an ideal place to
look uh for this so there was a a really
cool 2018 paper uh by Abe and colleagues
the title was skeletal muscle mass and
human athletes what is the upper limit
where essentially they've recruited 95
extremely muscular athletes nice uh
including 43 American football players
18 power lifters 28 sumo wrestlers and
six shot Putters and they were just
trying to characterize the limits of
human muscularity that's awesome yeah so
they they looked at their their like
fat-free Mass but then they also so it's
hard to directly measure how much
skeletal muscle mass people have but
like there's there's a validated
equation that is based on like looking
at ultrasound thicknesses on I think
like eight or nine different sites and
then like scaling to body height and
whatnot and these are like muscles that
are particularly thick where like most
of your like it's going to be pretty
representative of your total skeletal
muscle tissue
um so yeah it is a prediction equation
but like it it's probably it's close
enough for government work okay
um and so out of these 95 uh extremely
muscular like super jacked guys uh only
seven of them had more than 50 kilograms
of skeletal muscle tissue which like
that's a shitload and the peak was
59.3 kilograms of skeletal muscle mass
so what sport did he play which one was
he uh I don't think it's said okay I
mean so I mean just
just looking at his numbers I think he's
a defensive tackle in football that's
yeah
he is a CL he just the stats look like
the classic guy that's just gonna line
up over Center and just just eat up
double teams and triple teams to let to
let the linebackers Run free we love to
see it yeah this guy was a monster so
um shout out yeah his his total body
mass was
168.7 kilos uh he had 110.6 total kilos
of fat free mass at 1.9 meters tall for
Americans listening is about 375 had
like 245 pounds of fat free mass at six
three that's that's a beefy laugh that's
a big guy
um so yeah we'll we'll just use him as
our example for
if we take the numbers from the Holtman
study and scale to skeletal muscle mass
how how much would this guy need to
consume to maximize muscle creatine
concentrations
and so like just rounding up saying like
yeah he's got about 60 kilos of of
muscle mass
using the 2 gram uh like point of
reference from the Holtman study about
0.0625 grams per kilo of skeletal muscle
that would work out to about 3.75 grams
for this guy who's a monster and
using uh three grams as that point of
comparison which worked out to about
.09375 grams per kilogram uh for for
again this absolute tank that would be
uh like 5.625 grams
so yeah like
even for this guy like five grams a day
would be within that range of amounts
that would probably maximize muscle
creatine concentrations and maintain
maximum concentrations but if if this
one guy wanted to take a better safe
than sorry dose of creatine yeah maybe
he could bump it up to six grams but
like
if you're not
built like a professional football
player like offensive defensive lineman
or a professional sumo wrestler trust me
five grams a day is plenty yeah like
that is already the better safe than
sorry dose nice that's a great
illustration thank you I do my best
all right so that does it for the
pre-prepared material yeah I have is is
there anything else you want to bring up
or discuss
no all right let's uh let's get into the
question let's do it so we have three
questions that are also related to
creatine that came in to the inbox again
if you'd like to ask a question for us
to answer on the show uh send it to
podcast at strongerbyscience.com uh
record a voice clip Max 60 seconds and
uh yeah we'll we'll listen to all of
them and respond to the ones that we
like
so yeah let's uh let's listen to the
first question
hi Greg and Lindsay love the new podcast
format Greg in your article Don't Close
the Door on Creatine yet you say that in
real terms the Burke meta-analysis
suggests that creatine can help us build
muscle about one third faster on average
does this mean creatine will simply help
us get to our genetic potential faster
or do you think that it raises the bar
on what would otherwise be naturally
achievable
thank you in advance for your thoughts
all right that was that was Andy Morgan
shout out to Andy hi Andy uh
rippedbody.com
athletebody.jp cool guy
um
so yeah
this question asking about whether
creatine actually increases the total
amount of muscle you can grow or whether
it just might help you gain muscle a
little bit faster
I think it's primarily the latter
um I do think like
obviously just increasing muscle
creatine concentrations in the water
that comes along with it if you were at
your like genetic ceiling for muscle
growth and then started taking creatine
like yeah like your total muscle mass
might increase a little bit just due to
again the creatine and Associated Water
but that's not really what people are
talking about when they're asking about
building muscle yeah
see I I kind of think that it just
increases the rates of gains and
probably doesn't affect the ceiling all
that much although like
I'm I'm sympathetic to the idea that
like maybe it could around around the
fringes like if it's suppressing
myostatin a little bit maybe you confuse
a couple more myonuclei than you would
have otherwise maybe the fiber can then
get a little bit bigger than it would
have otherwise
um you know so I'm I'm sympathetic to
the idea that that it could potentially
ever so slightly raise that ceiling of
what you can achieve but I am doubtful
that it would have a particularly large
effect if it has an effect at all okay
uh next question from Chris bortle hi
Greg and Lindsay my question is about
creatine there's a lot of different
types on the market you can buy creatine
monohydrate creatine nitrate creatine
phosphate and all the others I know
creatine monohydrate is the most studied
but is there any worth in buying any of
the other forms lens what if what have
you heard about
other forms of creatine just like
non-monohydrate forms of creatine
so the thing that I've heard about
monohydrate specifically is that you
need to drink it pretty soon after you
mix it with water and that other forms
of creatine that you can buy don't have
that limiter and so
there might be ones that do slightly
better
um if you need to kind of like mix them
in something
long before you're actually going to
drink it but that's really all I know
hmm you know so that that actually isn't
one of the things that I had heard about
other forms of creatine but that that
does make sense
um the type of creatine that you will
sometimes see in beverages like that
that you would buy at the gas station
that like caffeinated stuff that also
has a little bit of creatine which I'll
also note like those are those are a
scam I think because like they have
maybe a hundred milligrams of creatine
in them like not not enough to really do
anything
um but the version of creatine that
you'll sometimes see in them is Cree
alkaline uh which I assume means that
it's creatine bounded to something that
would like make the solution slightly
more alkaline and so yeah creatine does
uh break down to creatinine in solution
and the rate at which that reaction
occurs is dependent on temperature and
pH so if something is cold old and in a
basic environment so like the opposite
of acidic the rate of creatine breakdown
to creatinine will be slower and if it's
hotter or in a more acidic environment
the rate will be faster
um
so yeah like if if you're just mixing it
in water I I don't have the references
in front of me right now but like
I think you can leave creatine in water
at room temperature for like several
hours and like some breakdown will occur
but like in excess of 90 of the creatine
will still be in there
um but yeah like if you uh mixed it in
something acidic like orange juice or
coffee like you would need to drink it
right away okay
um or like if you wanted to leave it for
like days and days at a time yeah
um so yeah that that does kind of make
sense and I mean that's something that I
read somewhere but I don't know where so
it could be wrong it may have been some
sales copy but yeah so like like that
makes a little bit of sense like a
creatine that is bound to something that
it would dissociate from in solution and
the the thing itself would be kind of
basic to reduce rates of creatine
breakdown like I I can see that again
like probably not relevant to most
people but like I I get where that's
coming from okay
um so yeah most of the other forms of
creatine that I'm aware of at least
are mostly marketed based on claims
about solubility so uh creatine
I I believe needs to dissolve into
solution for it to be absorbed
um and also if it doesn't go into
solution it's more likely to cause like
GI distress oh yeah so you can't like
dry scoop it like some people like to do
I mean I dry scoop it here's okay here's
the thing like
I dry scoop it and then swish it around
in my mouth with liquid like there's
some mechanical agitation there and also
like I think that I think that a lot of
the concern about that is a little
overblown because the thing is it gets
into your small intestine it's wet in
there like even if even if famously it
is every cells need to be wet yeah and
you're yeah your your intestines are are
wet like they're they have plenty of
liquid in them great so yeah even if
creatine isn't in solution when it
actually makes it to your small
intestine it will have probably gone
into solution at some point as it's
traveling along the like extremely long
small intestine and then it can get
absorbed so yeah like I I think a lot of
that is overblown but yeah that is a a
common thing that uh like alternate
forms of creatine are marketed for like
improved solubility
um
and so yeah my general take is that if
you get like GI issues when using
creatine monohydrate I think it's
probably worth experimenting with
alternate forms of creatine that maybe
have a little bit better solubility like
it yeah it might make your tummy a
little bit happier you can also just use
plain creatine monohydrate but uh the
marketing term is micronized creatine
um which is literally just creatine
monohydrate that they process to make
like the little granules slightly
smaller because like like a lot of
chemicals
um creatine will just like spontaneously
form little crystals as you kind of so
it's it's in solution as they're
processing it and then they dry it out
and like
some little crystals will form so
micronized creatine is essentially they
just break up those crystals so they're
a lot smaller and go into solution
easier
um and so yeah like I I think probably
micronized creatine is what I would go
with first if you get some tummy issues
and then if you want to try some of the
other forms of creatine Go For It
ultimately I don't think it's going to
have like a meaningful effect on on the
ergogenic properties of creatine because
like the the peak muscle concentrations
it's like 160 millimoles per kilogram of
dry Mass alternate forms of creatine
I I am not aware of a way that would
allow allow them to like exceed that
limit and help you reach muscle
concentrations of creatine that can't be
achieved with monohydrate yeah but yeah
like if if you want to try them out for
for tummy issues go for it
okay uh last question from Alisha
hey just super quick question I was just
wondering if creatine and caffeine has a
inhibitory effect on each other meaning
should I have to pick one or the other
um can I not drink a cup of tea if I
take creatine or should I space them out
by a couple hours or something does it
even matter can I take it together
thanks
uh lens have have you heard about this
at all like the I definitely have heard
of the idea that you shouldn't mix
creatine and caffeine
and I think that the reason that I've
heard
you shouldn't do that is that it can
increase the likelihood of
gastrointestinal issues
but I don't know much about it yeah
um so yeah I think I think you probably
got that from Eric's creatine guy
probably that's where I know most things
from about creatine from yeah that makes
sense
um but yeah so there was a study by
vanderberg and colleagues from 1996
um that that is is what got people
thinking about this for the first time
uh essentially it was it was looking at
the effects of creatine and caffeine
supplementation on knee extension torque
and I don't have this study pulled up in
front of me and I didn't review it again
before
recording this episode but I think I
remember and if I'm wrong about this I'm
close enough whatever don't sue me
um but so if if memory serves creatine
increased knee extension torque caffeine
increase knee extension torque taking
both creatine and caffeine together did
not increase knee extension torque oh so
that got people thinking like maybe
they're inhibitory yeah or you know
maybe it's just a reasonably small study
that just had like a false null you know
like that's also a possibility
and the thing is like they're having
there haven't been a ton of studies
since then that
um
that have looked at this topic but there
was one by hespol in 2002 looking at
muscle relaxation times suggesting that
creatine and caffeine have different
effects on muscle relaxation times like
one of them increases it one of them
decreases it's like maybe they're at
odds there what does muscle relaxation
time mean
so when
for your muscles to contract uh your
there's there's a stimulus coming from a
motor nerve that if it's sufficient it
causes a depolarization wave to go down
the the membrane of the muscle fiber
that causes release of calcium from the
sarcoplasmic reticulum which then allows
actin to to bind to myosin because it
moves the troponin off of off of The
Binding sites and uh the the
depolarization wave is driven by sodium
flowing into the cell calcium coming
back or a potassium flowing out and
basically like four
all of that to happen again you need to
like let everything come back to
Baseline a little bit you need to pump
okay potassium back in you need to pump
sodium out you need to re-sequester some
of the calcium and like we're talking
things that happen on like yeah like sub
millisecond levels
um
but yeah so in general like uh
like fast twitch muscle fibers have like
faster muscle relaxation times and the
faster the relaxation time is the sooner
the muscle can be or the fiber can be
re-stimulated and like have another
bout of contraction
um
anyway whatever doesn't matter thank you
you're very welcome uh
so there was like another study by
Harris in 2005 looking at knee extension
torque uh Trexler himself Eric Trexler
as part of his master's research I
believe
um did did a study on caffeine creatine
in the combination of the two
um and uh then there was a more recent
study by pakulak in 2021 that was the
only longitudinal study of the bunch
um
and essentially like it's this weird
place where like the different effects
on relaxation time like that doesn't
seem to be like a strong enough
mechanism to like really explain what's
going on
um but like most of these studies do
kind of suggest an inhibitory effect so
like in the uh Vandenberg study the
hespel study the Hera study and the Paco
lack study
um creatine on its own seemed to work so
like in the three acute studies it
improved measures of performance
um in the pakalak study which was a
longitudinal study it caused an increase
in knee extensor thickness
but in all five of these studies the
combination of creatine and caffeine
didn't quote unquote work
um like
sometimes the direct comparison to just
creatine was significant sometimes it
was non-significant but creatine plus
caffeine didn't outperform Placebo in
any of these studies which is which is
like weird and when you talk to
like I I don't consider myself like a
supplement expert guy but when you talk
to supplement expert guys or gals
um that's very inclusive of you thank
you uh they're they exist uh
they will largely say ah don't worry
about this like there's there's no like
strong mechanistic accounting for why
this would be the case
um
we we can't think of a good reason like
a strong enough reason to suspect that
creatine and caffeine would be directly
inhibitory
but the the admittedly small body of
research on the topic does suggest that
there might be inhibitory effects here
but again like it's a small body of
research yeah there's not much looking
into like mechanistic effects and for
all of the things being studied you
would expect creatine and caffeine both
to have relatively small effects on the
outcomes being being discussed and so
like who knows like maybe maybe it is
inhibitory maybe it isn't uh Eric
proposed in his creatine guide that um
if if there is something that looks like
an inhibitory effect it might just be
like GI discomfort from people taking
creatine and caffeine at the same time
and if that's the case like I use
caffeine in the morning take creatine in
the afternoon everything should be fine
yeah but I mean it is also possible that
there is some sort of like direct
inhibitory effect and just like the
mechanisms haven't been discovered yet
um just a quick thing about like
figuring out dosing you don't need to
take creatine like right before a
workout for it to be effective for the
workout right like it's just kind of
getting it into your system right yeah
yeah so if you wanted to like just take
your creatine in the morning and you're
going to work out in the afternoon and
you want to take caffeine before your
workout it seems like that would work
yeah that would also be fine uh and that
is worth I think like briefly touching
on a little bit
um so we we do sometimes get questions
about like creatine dosing like should
you split it into multiple doses
take it should you take it with other
things whatever
um and for like like from for the most
part it doesn't really matter but you it
could matter to you if you're trying to
do everything like quote unquote
optimally so ultimately yeah it's it's
what you're getting at like you're just
trying to fully saturate your muscle
creatine levels yeah and when you do
that you're good like the the whether or
not you have like a fresh batch of
creatine in your system is irrelevant
yeah if you reach that point of
saturation you're good to go
um when you take creatine will influence
that a little bit so creatine uptake
into the muscle is a little bit greater
after a workout than it would be at
other times in the day um so
like that again like that doesn't matter
like if if for most people most of the
time yeah if you're if you've been
taking it for months and you already
have saturated muscle creatine levels
whether you take it after a workout or
at any other point in time is completely
irrelevant to you and if you're just
starting to take creatine and you're
trying to like saturate your muscle
creatine levels uh taking it after a
workout might mean that you reach like
saturation at three and a half weeks
instead of four like we're and again if
you're if you're going to be taking it
for months yeah years which which you
should like that's it's good for you
yeah
um
if you're going to be taking it for
months to years like taking three extra
days to reach full saturation irrelevant
but like
technically sure if you're just starting
to take it after a workout is the best
time to take it but again don't
worry about that
um
and then second thing is is similar with
uh it's a similar type of deal for
taking creatine with other stuff so
creatine absorption and muscle creatine
uptake seems to be a little bit greater
if you consume it with some carbohydrate
instead of just yeah itself
those two things are probably related as
well like both like like exercise kind
of primes muscles to just absorb
nutrients
um and consuming some carbohydrate you
get like
insulin effects kind of prime cells to
absorb stuff and so like yeah like
consuming creatine after a workout with
a carbohydrate Source will probably
improve absorption and uptake into the
muscles a little bit but once you reach
full saturation who cares like
because you're you're saturated and you
will stay saturated yeah and you're good
to go
um
what what was the other oh uh last thing
I wanted to note though is is like
multiple doses per day if you if you get
an ouchy tummy when you take creatine
that might be something worth
experimenting with
um You probably don't need to take it
all as like a single bolus so if you're
taking five grams a day and that bothers
your tummy but two or three grams a day
doesn't or like two or three grams in a
single dose doesn't you could split it
into two doses you can split it into
three doses that's totally fine uh and
if you're doing a loading phase which
again you you don't need to do but if
you want to
um I would definitely recommend
splitting a loading phase into multiple
doses because even if a maintenance dose
of creatine doesn't give you an upset
tummy like 25 grams at once a lot
there's a decent chance it will so yeah
you probably should split that into
multiple doses
um but yeah so so just to just to Circle
back to to the question that we're
directly answering about different forms
of creatine
just just reiterating creatine
monohydrate will fully saturate your
muscle creatine levels that is
ultimately what you're trying to
accomplish alternate forms of creatine
as far as we know don't let you achieve
higher levels of total creatine
concentrations than you can get with
just monohydrate
um but some of them might dissolve a
little bit better and so if you don't
mind the extra cost because like all of
them are more expensive than monohydrate
if you don't mind the extra cost and you
your the GI effects of monohydrate are
too severe for you and you don't want to
split the monohydrate up into multiple
Doses and you don't just want to take
micronized monohydrate you can
experiment with the other kinds of
creatine but like
I'm I'm like weekly anti other forms of
creatine because I yeah I do think the
the like literal cost outweighs the
benefits because they do cost more and
the benefits if they exist
I think are probably trivial and can
probably just be avoided by taking
either micronized monohydrate or
monohydrate split into multiple doses I
think that's good to note that was the
prior question the question we were on
was creatine and caffeine oh you're
right you're right yeah I that's okay
that was a great summary for the last
question do you want to give a creatine
and caffeine summary or do you feel like
we've covered that uh creatine and
caffeine summary is basically like
there's
there's not a great reason to think they
would be inhibitory except for all of
the research
but there's also not enough research to
be like super confident about it yeah
um so I I think it's one of those things
where it's like if you wanted to be like
extremely better safe than sorry about
it and say hey I'm going to choose
whether I'm taking caffeine or creatine
but not both
I I would not begrudge you that
um I I kind of think that if
if there is an effect it is probably
related to like acute like acute effects
of Co ingestion whether that be upset
tummies or something else yeah was that
what the studies like was that the
design for the studies they were taking
creatine and caffeine together right
before a workout
um
I mean I would guess that's probably
what they were doing I yeah I I haven't
looked into this in a while or maybe
ever I suspect they were though yeah
because like you're going to like you're
going to give people the caffeine before
their workouts and if you're already
like supervising the supplement
Administration you're not gonna like
have them come in the morning and take
it yeah yeah
um so yeah like I don't know I it's it's
one of those things where like I I
really just don't see a strong reason
why they should be inhibitory but like
the research this point suggests that
they might be but doesn't really provide
a reason why so yeah like if you want to
be super conservative about it and only
take one or the other I get where you're
coming from I do kind of suspect though
that if you just take them at different
times you're you're probably going to be
good nice
um but I'm not like super confident in
that
that's all I got on Creatine for this
episode that's it thanks for listening
do you have anything else you want to
discuss before we wrap up I do not
perfect
uh so thank you for listening to another
episode of The Stronger by science
podcast we we love and appreciate you
all
um once again if you like the show uh
like and read it wherever you listen to
podcasts it does help the show a lot and
if you would like your questions to be
answered on a future episode uh send us
those voice clips 60 seconds or less to
podcast at strongerbyscience.com uh and
until next week hope you have a good one
two weeks until two weeks from now uh
hope you have a good one have it have a
great Fortnight yes